this is jocko podcast number 284
with echo charles and me jocko willink
good evening echo good evening
anybody home right from the very
threshold of our bungalow
reached us a hoarse voice of an elderly
gentleman
the voice woke us up at high noon of our
first day amid the date palms of the
settlement outside saddam's palace
somewhere at the outskirts of baghdad
hi guys this greeting that followed
sounded a bit warmer
our shared english proved to be good
enough so we were able to freely
exchange greetings with our visitor
and learn what he wanted from us or
rather as it turned out
what that older feller could do for us
in our iraqi reality
my name is posey bill posey and i am the
boss here
he introduced himself to us clad in an
american uniform
pants and a brown t-shirt in case you
need anything lads
just bring me the list and i'll take
care of it
that was how bill posey greeted us at
one time he might have been a strapping
lad
indeed but in spite of age he lost
nothing of his military appearance
and his advanced age only dignified him
he brought us a box full of batteries in
this climate they run out no time guys
and you'll generally operate at night
each of you must have a large supply of
them he explained putting the box
on the table that is how i remember my
first encounter with bill posey
our visitor turned out to be one of the
oldest if not the oldest navy seals to
serve in combat in that legendary u.s
navy unit his vast experience and
involvement impressed people
and used his age to his advantage bill
posey's
knowledge on military bases how they
work like ours in baghdad
seemed unlimited bill posey volunteered
with the u.s navy
at a time when most young american males
did their best
to steer clear of military service
some of his civilian friends even faked
injuries or feigned
joint problems fearing fit for duty
opinion of the draft board
which would have meant an unwanted
conscription
but no wonder in the late 1960s
indochina was the scene of the brutal
vietnam war
and after all not every young guy had a
warrior's
soul
during his service in the udt underwater
demolition
teams in vietnam posey with other udt
men
and seals took part in many combat
missions in patrols
in later time he also secured the
landing of apollo 12
but when he volunteered to the first
gulf war in 1990
the medical board rejected him saying he
was too old for further duty
however in 2003 he deployed to baghdad
he built the camp infrastructure from
scratch took care of our supplies
and he was also an expert on our
vehicles and he was a very generous man
he raised money on the base for a
catholic orphanage in baghdad
but he also remained a warrior until the
last days of his service
including taking part in combat
operations
the guy was devoted to the fight and to
his teammates throughout his entire
career
no wonder then that our base in baghdad
was named after him
camp posey camp jenny posey
to be exact bill posey had a daughter
who was also in the service but in the
army
he said that since the commanding
officer desired to name the base camp
posey after him
he humbly let it be named in honor not
of him
but of his daughter hence the full name
of our base
was camp jenny posey
and that right there was an excerpt from
a book
which is actually called camp posey
written by polish special operations
soldier
from the grom named naval polska
and this part of the book about the
polish special operations unit
working with seals in iraq this is a
book that i talked about when i had my
brother tom
drago zaran on here for podcast 276
and that book by naval polska is called
camp posey and as you heard camp jenny
posey
was named after the daughter of the
vietnam era frogman warrant officer bill
posey
who fought in vietnam recovered the
apollo 12
space capsule and who ultimately built
camp jenny posey in baghdad
and did combat operations with the seals
and the grom
in iraq and we are lucky enough
to have this legend here with us tonight
udt seal team vietnam iraq
frogman and legend warrant officer
bill posey he's here
warrant bill thanks for coming on
commander it's always great being here
i thought you weren't going to call me
jonco and now you're calling me
commander i guess i wasn't supposed to
call you warren
you know old habits die or very slowly
and uh
at group one where i was at a lot of the
time
we really respected you and your ability
to lead and your ability to push things
through
so uh you were a legend at
group one uh not bill posey i was only a
legend in my own mind
well sometimes i got in trouble for
pushing things through but it was okay
so let's talk let's start at the
beginning i mean this is a pretty
awesome story for you to spend so much
time in the teams and so much time
just keeping that keeping the
brotherhood on the path
but it started you grew up in in
california right
california yes sir and what was the
situation there
um you know it it when i grew up it was
after world war ii we were the first
part of the
baby boom so it was really nothing but
optimism especially in southern
california because there was nothing
here
there was hardly any people especially
in the los angeles area so everything
just blew out of the ground
and it was an amazing place to be there
you know we could surf the freeways went
in
so some days we could surf in the
morning
and then get an afternoon lift ticket up
at big bear
and ski in the afternoon how can you
beat that living the dream yeah
you could surf you could ski they had
beautiful women
i mean what more does a man want i mean
it's the place
uh my kid my son as soon as he got his
driver's license he was on that mission
and it's a lot easier now even though
the traffic's worse guess what they got
night skiing up there
there you go he's like oh surfing in the
morning going night skiing at night on
the same plan
what so you you mentioned um the baby
boomers so was what about your your dad
was your dad
in the military yeah my dad was in the
navy he came from victoria texas uh
to long beach and he was on a ship
called the uss cummings
and he was stationed out of long beach
and then did the south pacific
he met my mother in southern california
he took my mother after you married her
to victoria texas and said this is where
i want to go
and she says no we're not going to
victoria texas we're staying in southern
california
no air conditioning in that time so it
was rough total game change yes sir
so when uh what what was your dad's war
experience like
on the uss commons he was a gunner
on the deck of the ships and he was a
bosun's mate so that's what he did and
he was in a couple of big battles there
and they didn't sink him so that's good
so he
he had a very positive and my mother
also who worked for the navy
had a very positive uh idea of the navy
and that kind of bled over to me
so and then what what did your dad do
after the navy
did he get out after the war yes sir got
out after the war and immediately went
to work for the telephone company for 40
years
was the lineman or what was he doing
there the guy that climbs the pulse
just getting it whole life yeah so
he was a very good guy and a very hard
worker
really a hard working guy so
i tried to be as much as like him as
possible
the week before he died he was 82 years
old and he was climbing a ladder on a
second story painting the eaves of my
daughter
his daughter's house so i'm an 82 that's
pretty good yeah
not no slowing down i guess we know
where you got your genetics from
so then you're growing up and
this is like just prime kind of prime
america
you're in southern california you got
you got surfing
where are you going surfing at uh you
know we did it all up and down the coast
from santa barbara to san diego
because it was easy to do and gas was
like 29 cents a gallon so we could do
whatever we want to just leave early in
the morning and there was hardly any
crowds
especially well bef what really
changed surfing was the type of material
they used in surfboards
so originally they used an epoxy well
originally was balsa wood but that was
before my time
but when foam came out they had
the foam but it was a polyester foam and
if you wanted to
resonate you would have to either put
tar or paper
over the res over the surfboard blank
so it was very difficult to do and you
always had voids where the
resin went down into the uh surfboard
material and you had a void
so when the polyurethane came out that
revolutionized the sport
game-changer yeah it was easy to do much
stronger much lighter it was it changed
the sport of surfing so what years were
you in high school
what year did you graduate from high
school uh 65 61 through 65.
and so you're going to high school and i
mean vietnam hadn't started yet until
just barely probably just started to
hear about it in 65. yeah
no it was going okay then and everybody
thought
well we can kind of tiptoe around it and
do other things uh
to avoid the work because nobody wanted
to to go because
you know the draft was on and it was a
different type of military
so typically if you were drafted you
were drafted in the army very few people
into the marine corps none in the navy
or the air force
so you would go into the army you would
go to vietnam you would come back
in a plastic bag so it wasn't a good
deal
you know they just didn't think it
through and it wasn't a good deal for
draftees
so when you're going to high school were
you thinking about the military
as you were going to high school no not
at all we're thinking about how we can
avoid the military
it was a negative sense rather than
positive and you were kind of like a
motorhead right
yeah i i will always turn to rich from
the time i was a little kid
i was always building cars or building
different things so i was really happy
in that world
so give us i mean give us the highlights
what was the what was the prize because
what were the beauties
well i had a low budget low ditch uh car
i had a 55 chevy with a
31 ford front end on it uh the axle and
everything
with a 348 and a muncie four speed
so i thought i was a cat's meow
on tweedy boulevard we had this street
called tweedy boulevard where everybody
cruised right
and it was the longest dead end street
in the world and everybody would cruise
on it and you know you see all your
girlfriends and
you know it was really good i mean it
was like i don't know what that movie
was with ron howard
but i mean it was much more
fun was it diner no uh
god i can't remember that movie with ron
howard i know the one you're talking
about it was in the 50s
and it really looked good in the movies
but the 50s were really better than that
because that was the optimism of the 40s
and the 50s
that america can do it all we can do it
scientifically and our lives will be
forever better and there'll never be a
down time
because my father was a depression-era
kid right
and they had completely different values
than we had
in the 50s because we thought there was
no end i mean
we could do whatever we wanted nobody in
my family
extended family in texas and in
california had ever been to college
nobody so i tell my father when i
graduate from high school he says well i
want you to go to work for the telephone
company it's a great job
and you can work the job for 40 years
right i said dad
i'm not i'm not going to be hanging from
some telephone pole
in south central los angeles that was a
specialty because he could get so much
overtime and i said i'm not doing that
he says you know you're really not very
bright
i don't think you're going to make it to
college well he was right there but
you know what can you say did you play
any sports or anything in high school
yeah i did the good seal team sports i
played water polo swam and did cross
country
and track so it was real good it was
really
kind of prophetic doing those sports and
being able to do
you know seal team or udt at the time
were what kind of music were you
listening to you know typical southern
california
beach boy jan and dean
i i you know i tell i'm a schoolteacher
now
and the kids have a lot of problems now
i mean they have a lot of
interpersonal problems right and i tell
them about my experience and they look
at me
wow i mean it was the greatest in my
opinion the greatest time ever to be
alive
well did we since you work with kids now
like what's the difference
i mean i was thinking from from you're
talking about cars right yes
and when you have cars like a 1955 car
that's a car that any well most
people can look at and fully understand
what's absolutely you know
there's no magic to it that's right and
now you open up the hood of a
new car just like your point in the book
if you make it simple everybody
understands yeah
and it seems like the cars back then if
there was a problem with it you could
pretty easily identify what the problem
was and be like oh it's a carburetor or
whatever
and we just get that thing fixed but now
it's hard to even tell there's so many
complications inside of a car
that it seems like kids these days also
are faced with all these different
complications
as opposed to hey um you know this is
what we're gonna go surfing and then we
go to big bear we're gonna go skiing
that sounds like a
kind of thing you want to deal with as a
kid right now they're dealing with
social media peer pressure and all this
other crap yeah it's a much harder life
it's much more difficult and i see a lot
of these kids
in my line of work being really stressed
out by other kids
especially the girl on girl situation
where
one's chiding or bullying the others you
know
and and the beauty of it is and i don't
know if you experienced this in your
high school
but the beauty of it is if we were mad
at somebody
we go out in the parking lot and duke it
out not that i was a big fighter because
i was as big as round as a pencil you
know
but i mean but that's hot you know that
fight that fist fight in the parking lot
and i don't want my kids at school fist
fighting because i'd get
fired but that little fight in the
parking lot really earned
uh respect from your peers and it taught
you
hey i can't be badmouthing these guys
because he's going to sucker punch me
and and straighten me out so but they
don't have that now
you know and i've been at my high school
for eight years
and i've never seen one fight wow it's
just a different mindset
i'm sure at your high school was there a
fighter yeah there's fights
and and not to mention you get into a
seal platoon and there's like a fight
every 14 minutes
if you need it or not yeah someone's
getting hit someone's getting choked
someone's getting pummeled that's just
the way it is
[Laughter]
so you you uh you grow up there in
southern california
kind of just straight up living the
dream yes sir
sounds outstanding and i got a job when
i was 15 and a half in a grocery store
and it was
everything was unionized in so i started
at 90 cents an hour which was big money
for a 15 year old kid
so i was able some weeks
when i was a senior in high school i
made more of my father who had been
at his job for 20 years right and so i
could buy
so many car parts it was unbelievable
never saved a dime
was i was i smart if i had to save 10
of that i'd have been living in san
diego right now
[Laughter]
so you so you uh as you're getting ready
to graduate you know you're not going to
college
no i went to college for two you did
yeah okay i went to college and college
was very difficult then because
everybody was trying to cheat the draft
so
classes didn't have 25 people in it they
had
50. you know and you would beg the
instructor to take you into the class
because if not if you went below 12
units then you're open
fodder for the draft so i always tried
to take 15 or 18 units
just in case i had to back out so i went
to college because i wanted to be
21 when i went to service so i could
drink legally
right so that was my goal to be 21 and
to be in the service
i thought the drinking age was 18 back
then no not in california
not in california and texas it was but
not in california when i joined the navy
in the
the drinking age was 21 but at the e
club on nab coronado you could drink at
18.
but you couldn't drink at the trade
winds the team bar
you couldn't go to the team bar right
you're thinking way more strategic than
i was
strategic thinker i mean come on so you
get done with so now so you graduate
high school in 1965 you go to two years
what college did you go to
compton and and you're studying what are
you studying anything
auto mechanics oh so you're just getting
into it yeah i'm trying to perfect my
uh my ability to fix things are you
racing cars
yeah well i mean just street racing
illegal street racing
and and what car are you driving now did
you graduate from the 55 oh no no
the 55 chevy took a lot of different
engines and different drive train setups
and stuff like that so it was good for
me
and then at what point did you start
thinking all right i'm not going to be
able to was it did you make it to 21
before you got
before you joined the navy so you made
it to 21. no in 1966 i joined the navy
because the draft was closing in
as they needed more men um you had
different steps
so if you have if you were married then
you avoided the draft if even
if you were going to school but you
weren't willing to make that kind of
great no no no no no
you weren't that nuts right i mean
yeah you weren't willing to go that
distance you know when the women in
southern california at that time were
incredible
and you grew up where
the women always took the pill well
that's not true because the pill came
out in the early 60s
but nobody took it for a while so when
the pill came about
it was a whole new different social
scene
and you know everybody got their jihad
on
if you know what i mean and so it was
very
fruitful to be a a young man
and a young woman in southern california
in 1965.
and so so you're so you're getting your
your jihad on
and and then so at what point are you
did you say you joined the navy yeah we
joined it in 1966 the draft was closing
in
and everybody had tried to get into a
national guard unit
or a reserve unit so there was nothing
left because everybody of draft
eligibility did that
so i went into the summer marine
submarine reserves which was the least
desirable of any reserves right because
you had to go into summary
and so i did that and that
proved my gateway to go into seal team
i'm going to tell you the little story
if you wouldn't mind commander
so i'm on this ship and i'm turning a
wrench right i wanted to be in the
engine room because i wanted to see how
those
you know diesel motor was probably uh
15 feet long and it was a real good
learning experience because i learned a
lot of things about diesel
but the problem is you couldn't take a
shower in the submarine
because there was no in the showers they
had potatoes
because there was no room we had about
85 people on the submarine there was no
room
for anything including the shower so you
were out to sea for two weeks at a time
and as an engineman you were really
greasy
and you could wash yourself but you
couldn't really get yourself clean
so you get in your rack and you put your
face on your pillow
and you know you wake up in four hours
for your next gig
and your face is so greasy that
your your face slid off the pillow right
and i didn't like to be greasy i didn't
mind muddy or dirty but greasy
it's not good you know when you had
pimples on your face and this is the
worst part
so we used to go to a bar down here in
san diego i can't remember the name of
the the
boat bar and you'd walk in
and people would smell you before they
would see you because
it was a snorkel submarine where the the
boat snorkeled to recharge the batteries
and it permeated everything with diesel
fuel so you smell like diesel fuel
so people would you walk in the bar
people would sniff and
say oh my god where'd this guy come from
and you're perfectly clean i mean your
skin's clean
but you just stink like diesel fuel
right
so after you know a little while on that
summary and i went to the cobb the chief
of the boat and i said cop
you know i'm really not a quitter this
is a volunteer service and a submarine
i want to go to the army the army's good
because i can sit in the mud
and the mud you wash off and you don't
stink right so
so you're in there you're in the navy
reserves at this point but are you but
i'm activating but you're active after
duties so you join the reserves
you go through boot camp yes but you're
summaries boot camp
but you're active duty so you you don't
have any break you're straight up you
when you joined you joined
no you you had as long as you wanted to
kind of fake it in the reserves but
usually
it's a two-year gig so that's why i
joined and then when i was 21
it worked out my time schedule perfectly
right so then
then you were activated got it and then
you went
was submarine boot camp actually
different than regular boot camp no it
was up at uh
hunter's point in san san francisco and
the marines would drill you
and they tried to instill discipline and
it was like a nine-week school
it's because you you went to boot camp
but you only learned about submarines
because you're a detriment when you go
on that diesel submarine you know
submarines from world war ii not nukes
but diesel boats
and if you don't if you turn the wrong
valve
it could be the wrong you know it could
be all over for the entire summary
you've got to know what you're doing
when you're not summary
so we went to that boot camp and then
the next step did you not
did you not put two and two together on
one event to be on a submarine
because i wasn't the sharpest tool of
the shed but i knew there's one thing i
didn't want to
god bless the guys that are on
submarines absolutely look i've spent
probably
my whole navy career probably spent a
month on a submarine total maybe a month
and a half
and it doesn't take much to figure out
that it's a special it's a different
breed of human being that goes on there
and can deal with it
because you're in a confined space you
know there's someone that
sleeps in your bed when you're not
sleeping in your bed racking right yeah
it's called hot rack and echo charles so
this is the deal echo they only have so
many beds they have
more people than they have beds so when
it's your turn to go to sleep
someone you share a bed with someone or
maybe two people so you get to sleep for
six hours and when you get out of bed
someone else is getting into your bed
it's warm right so this is just
it's not normal it's not normal it's not
and they're just as greasy as you oh
maybe not greasier
yeah and and everything is confined
you know and you literally don't see the
sun
and so it's a so i'm just wondering you
didn't you didn't think too much
you didn't think to yourself oh well i'm
gonna be on a freaking aluminum can
underneath the ocean for months at a
time maybe that's not the right deal
yeah but that was just you know all my
friends
most of my friends joined the submarine
reserves and so then
they went on the submarines so that's
just the way it was
anything to avoid the army how long did
you spend on
in the submarine service a month and a
half not long at all
not long at all so after a month and a
half of smelling like diesel
and being stuck underwater you went to
the chief of the boat
right one time and that's where i cut
you off where you went to him and said
i said all right i'm done you know i i
just i just don't like it
and i'm not the right guy to be this you
know
and he says posey do i have a deal for
you he says you go down and take this
test this afternoon
at 12 o'clock and you can be a seal team
guy
and i said well nobody knew because this
is 1967.
nobody knew what it meant right what
seal team was
and i thought well seal team well they
have seals
i thought right seals and
i said well does that mean that you
train seals and to do tricks
for recruiting and he says they'll
explain it to you
so i go over to the a part of the base
and they put a hard hat outfit on me and
the first test was
to drop you over the side of the ship in
the bay
and you walk around on the bottom of the
of the bay for a half hour
to see if you're claustrophobic and so
they drop me over at the side
and they uh you know
i walk around for a half hour in the mud
you walk through the mud
and this is in the old school like what
is it the mark 8 dive helmet thing yeah
yeah you know yeah yeah and you know it
was real old school
it's real yeah and so that was part of
the examination
[Music]
so all of the sediment that's been there
for 150 years
i mean you took one step and you
couldn't see for the next five minutes
you know
so they had me walking around
and what else did they do with you oh
then then they pull you up and they
i said hey i passed the test where do i
where do i go what do i do
and they said well you have to take the
other test
and i said oh okay and nobody knew what
seal team was right
so i i talked to the guy there and he
was a dive guy and i said well what
sealed him he says
man it's the greatest you go down to san
diego
you lay on the beach you are a lifeguard
for marines who make
marine landings at uh at
uh camp pendleton right
and you have a girl under each arm and
in each hand
you have a beer and the navy buys you
beer
he said really the navy buys you beer
yeah and these girls are gorgeous
they're
they're wonderful down in san diego i
said
man that's the life for me that's what i
want to be right
so you didn't know because there's no
internet there's no books
i think men with green faces was his
first book if i'm not mistaken from
world war ii
and i checked that out of the library
and that didn't you know you didn't know
what you got there
so you just didn't know which was i
think
a plus where were where were you
stationed when all this was happening
long beach okay so then they transfer me
to san diego
and i go to the team area the friday
before training starts
and i go there and oliveira i don't know
if you ever heard
of him he's my proctor and i show up
at like four o'clock in the afternoon
and he says where you been
i said well they just brought me in the
bus here i don't know what to do
and he says i said what do i do what do
you want me to do
do i need a book bag because i thought
it was a school i didn't know
and he says no no no you don't need a
book bag you just show up monday morning
we're gonna take care of you he said
really yeah so
i go over at that time we had three
quonset huts at the end of
coronado at the end of the base and
i go there and he gets me a rack and so
i'm sitting there the weekend
and these guys come in and they tell me
what's happened and say
okay it is what it is right i'm not in
the army
so i'm pretty happy so that's how it
just all started then it started going
downhill monday morning
[Laughter]
so what was the wake-up call like monday
morning so you had no idea
not a clue you didn't know it was going
to be physical you didn't know nothing
about hell week nothing
you just thought you were going to a
navy school where you're going to learn
about
whatever right some demolition and that
type of thing
diving and it would be nothing where you
ran
or swam or whatever so what in your mind
as you start getting physically and
mentally abused at a
high level on monday morning what made
you decide okay well i'll just stick
with it hey
you know i've been in that see the
motivation is i'd been in that submarine
and there was no way in god's green
earth that i was going to go back to
that summary they're going to have to
kill me
i was not going back to that summary
no way so how did the training kick off
um you know it was just physical
training and evaluation and they gave us
the test
the sealed team test and everybody
passed it and
back then we had eight count burpees
in with the you know run floor exercise
and the swim
so but it was you know i was half the
man i
i am now so it was a lot easier
to uh to pass what class were you in uh
originally 44
then 45 and then 46. so you got rolled a
few times
yeah i got mumps the first time what the
hell what's
what's that mumps it's a disease a
childhood disease
from the 50s that they have an
inoculation your kids
got the shot right so you didn't get the
shot and you randomly got oh there was
no shot then
got it and then the second time i got
encephalitis
from the bay from the dirty water and
then they gave me some drugs and i got
over that in about four weeks and the
third time i was ready to go
then i knew what was going on you know
so
how far did you make it on each of those
previous occasions two weeks
and then three weeks and then away
you know 46 i was good
and did you did you start to understand
what the mission was that you were
getting yourself into yeah because
people explained it you know we had
extensive training at the tradewinds of
of what was happening and how things
went down
so then you got it you got you
understood what's going on
you know in that time it was much
different than it is now
because the navy controlled everything
you were a navy asset
all funding came from the navy as from
not from socom or being a national asset
like in seal team six
so it's always where the money comes
from what
you know how they dictate your life and
so
we were like the dog in the manger udt
even seal team because the navy you know
we were poisoned to the navy
if you wanted to make any headway you
had
to be a surface naval officer
uh to make any headway because there was
we never had an admiral
we never had anybody i believe well i
think we had a captain
so it was very difficult for people with
a career to do that
if you weren't an enlisted person so the
guys that were your instructors at this
time were these guys that had already
done tours over in vietnam because this
is what year is this now 1960
68 early 16th oh so you're definitely
getting guys that were coming back from
vietnam
right and they're telling you what's
going on and a big crowd of world war ii
folks
that they were still in because the
korean i mean the korean war
was over in 53 right and
world war ii was over in 45 so they
still had time in their career
to instruct at uh at buds at that time
it was udtra
so it was a different world what do you
remember
was did you have any trouble in training
in any of the evolutions
uh no not really uh i had trouble on the
last swim that four and a half mile swim
at san clemente and we just barely made
it within a minute
but you know the current was running
really hard
and i mean we were really kicking just
to make that
and a couple of guys didn't make it had
to do it again the next day
so i was really thankful for that big
swim
you know on that evolution to make it
but that's the only time i
had any trouble how big was your class
when you started
oh man i don't remember probably 43 or
45 maybe 50 people and then we i think
we whittle it down to 17.
so we didn't have that bad of an
attrition right
we had some really great guys in 44.
bill i don't know if you remember bill
wildrick great officer
i mean he was really an inspirational
guy
he could have been the poster boy for
your book
really a great guy so
he was really good to me for whatever
reason
so um one last question about buds
when when you're showing up you don't
know anything that's about to take place
it seems like guys now
they know kind of the minute by minute
schedule i was a little bit in between i
i
we didn't know a lot when i showed up to
buds like i had never heard of pool
competency which ends up being a huge
thing
i knew that there was a hell week thing
somewhere in there we stayed awake a
bunch
but you just didn't know what was
happening
what do you think you think that's
better or you think that's oh that's ten
times better
like one of my goals in life is
the navy has been very kind to me just
like the marine corps
has been kind you know thank god for the
navy in my life
i'm sure i'd have been in prison
otherwise right by the grace of god
and so i try to tell people especially
in small town texas
about the advantages of getting out of
texas
and getting out of our small town and
going seeing the world
so but a lot of them overthink it and
they just psych themselves out
it's just too bad that they publish as
much as they do because it's
in my opinion it's much better when you
stand up
and you just what are we going to do
next okay let's do it let's do it
let's get it on you know let's go
and so because i don't want to overthink
things
let's just do it yeah
did you um was going through hell week
do you remember anything special about
that for me i was kind of
i was kind of happy about hell week
because i wasn't the best athlete
so a swim and a run where he had a time
it was going to be
it was all those were hard for me to
pass i had to go basically the way i
passed
all my evolutions was by going as hard
as i possibly could
but i was always nervous you know
sometimes i'd be like you were talking
about like within a minute
of the drop dead time and i'd you know
be going to squat
yeah and we weren't you're not allowed
to wear a watch right so there's no pa
so for me i failed one run
in buds and because i tried to pace
myself
i tried to pace myself this is kind of
how i look at life now i try to pace
myself in one run and i failed
and i was like okay and from then on i
just ran as hard as i freaking possibly
could
and and that's how i passed but the the
thought of like
actually knowing each little detailed
thing that's going to come to you
when when it came to hell week i thought
there's no time limit i'll
they can't stop me i mean i'll keep
going no matter what
so i was kind of happy about hell week
it was one of the easier evolutions
because
there was no time limit you just had to
keep going which i was i look i might
not have been the fastest runner or the
fastest swimmer the best the obstacle
course
but i was good at keeping going i could
just keep going no matter what right
was how like how weak for you any any uh
big eureka moment that you discovered
anything no
just everybody was very nervous and we
had magic things that one class would
give the other
like we would have a magic shirt that i
got down from a guy by the name of gary
cronin he says
this has been passed down five times it
was a wool
shirt a long sleeve wool shirt that you
wore
under your jumper and he says if you
wear this shirt you're going to pass
heavily man give that
[ __ ] i don't care if it costs a hundred
dollars i want that shirt
right and then the other thing that
saved me
is i um i had illusions
or i was delusional on wednesday night
when we had the big paddle from
the area down to ib or whatever it was
and bill wilderick our crew chief our
crew officer was kind enough to let me
sleep for 15 minutes in the belly of the
boat
because i was i was having i mean i was
freaking out right
i was seeing monsters and all kinds of
different stuff
he said pose you lay down on this boat
and the rest of the guys paddle and
nobody complained
so you try to return the favor
however you possibly can to rest those
guys
you know be the first one out there get
the boat ready you know
pay him back for the nice thing they did
for you to allow you to go through hell
week
yeah i i had some guys that i saw
completely hallucinating things i had
one small hallucination but
i don't know if it really counts because
i knew it was a hallucination and while
it was happening i was like oh this is
we're out there on that thing i think
they call it around the world we're
doing around the world yes
and we're paddling and i'm we're in the
middle of the ocean
and all of a sudden i start seeing uh
traffic lights like
stop signs and traffic lights and it's
going to red green
and i'm looking i'm like i'm just
hallucinating that's not real
so i don't know if does that count what
do you think echo charles does that
count if you know it's fake but
it looks real yeah yeah okay that was
the only hallucinations i had no
monsters thankfully
i had one guy that started swearing like
language-wise
and he started swearing he didn't stop
for about 20 minutes
just every word freaking swearing and
everyone reached like hey is everything
okay [ __ ] yeah are you [ __ ] out
and we're like okay bro hey dude
whatever it takes man
just just stay in the boat man it's all
good but what are you going to do in the
ocean when that happens you have no
recourse you can't lay them on the deck
on the sand i mean what are you going to
do keep paddling yeah
paddle a little faster
at this time so it's 1968
at this time and i was talking to
roger hayden about this he said he said
that's a hero or mine i love that 100
100 yes sir he he said most
guys went to udt when they graduated
well there was three udts and one seal
team
he said occasionally a guy would go
straight to seal team but it was very
rare that's right
most guys were going to udt exp a lot of
people might not know about the udt
at that time what was going on with the
underwater demolition teams
at that time well on the west coast
there was udt 11 12 and 13.
13 was a new team they started i believe
in 67 and
disband i think it was 70 70 172
and so the navy was again our main
driver for funding and for manning for
everything
and so they wanted to keep udt
because if in case of an amphibious
landing or other
sorted things udt was useful to them
other than that
they had no time for you and there was
no funding so
like in our in our team we had three
pickup trucks and we had to go
once a day to 32nd street
to give them the surf
report so we would drive one pickup
truck
in the morning eight o'clock go to 32nd
street and come home that's the only
time we'd use that truck
because the other two pickup trucks we
had were in the team area but they were
up on cement blocks
because we robbed those for parts to
keep this one going
so there was just no no money and so we
just kind of made things happen
and but i think we were better for that
because we had
i mean when we went to vietnam we had a
parabag half full
because we had no gear there was no
reason to have a lot of gear because
we didn't have any money so
it really worked out well for me in my
naval career because i was able to
learn how to trade things with other
services and make things
happen and that really worked out to be
very good training for me to support my
sailors
my my goal was always to support my
fellow sailors
because the navy wasn't doing it well
nobody else was
so that was important so you got order
what what
udt team did you end up 13. so it's now
is it's 1969 now or is it still 68.
still 68. so it's 1968
you get your orders to udt team 13.
yes sir you walk down the grinder a
little bit
knock on a quonson hut is that basically
what happened there was forts
in the old cement people who don't know
about seal team don't know about that
old uh cement building that was there i
don't know if they've tore that down or
not
they tore everything down okay they tore
that down so it was probably
a hundred yards long and probably
you know a hundred feet uh wide
and that we had four teams in that
building you know seal team one
and then 11 12 and 13 udt so everybody
had a very
limited space and it was kind of
difficult but
one team was always or you know one and
a half teams because seal team was
always there
were always in vietnam so we had very
limited space
no resources at all and it was it was
difficult because of that
because there was just no room so when
you got to udt 13
you checked in what'd they do with you
did you go right into a platoon
no no they immediately sent you to
school because they were we were
deploying
and you had to go to seer school you had
to go
in my case i went to out border motor
school
to jump school and then it was just
timed
so the day you graduated from seer
school
you got an airplane and went to vietnam
did you get did you wear that old
insignia they like the
the udt insignia with no eagle on it no
no
that that wasn't there was no insignia
in 68
uh that came later and uh the insignia
you had is you had like a diver's helmet
on this
on your uniform right here and that was
the only insignia you had
and then of course on that
name badge right right and that there
was no team badge
there was nothing i'm going to tell you
a little story you probably heard this
many times
so we get the pirate
i don't know if you remember who pete
the pirate was i i i don't know his name
but i don't know
so he supposedly designed the insignia
for seal team right
because he was drinking budweiser one
day and he submitted like 20 designs
because they asked for
guys in the teams to to do design now
there's a lot of controversy about that
so about three months later
they walk into the quonset hut and they
said okay everybody's got their insignia
uh
you know and they gave us the they just
dropped this bag on the table and they
said okay everybody's got one of these
if you're an officer
you have a gold one if you're enlisted
you have a silver one
we're gonna have an inspection tomorrow
morning so uh
you know everybody's wow lance backs man
so we're out there standing on the
grinder some guy's got it on the right
side
some guys got it on the left side they
have it here they have it here
they they're thinking about putting it
on their dixie cup right
but i mean nobody knew what to do with
it right and so this was the original
trident
original udt insignia that was different
from the seal
trident so the udt insignia this is the
one basically that looks the same but
there's no eagle
that's correct and so nobody i mean
seal team had their thing going the same
morning everybody did the same thing
we just didn't know what to do and we
didn't know what it meant
and so that was it
what year did that happen was that after
you got back from vietnam yeah after we
got back from vietnam
so so you show up to to udt 13
do you you don't get put in platoon you
just get sent to see your school you get
sent to outboard motor school you get
sent to jump school there's no one
tracking you there's no one saying like
hey this is what we're getting ready to
do oh they're tracking you because as
soon as you get back you go to another
school
so they knew when you were coming back
and then they would immediately go to
another school
then you just jump on the airplane but i
knew what platoon i was in
i knew who my oac was and all that and
were those guys already overseas no no
they were
they were in the states so they're
they're shuffling you through all these
schools right when you got done with
schooling did you go through any kind of
pre-deployment workup like you know like
i did my whole career was like oh you're
getting ready to deploy you get
to platoon you you know you you uh first
you do
some schooling like you're talking about
the pro dev they call it professional
development so you go to a bunch of
schools
then it's six months of ult and then
it's six months of the advanced post
that and then you go onto plymouth now
we'll use none of that it was a weekend
at danny's
doing ult that's how that for people do
know what danny's is an
old-time team bar on uh in coronado and
that's
that was it so it was really ojt
and we had we relied on the guys
coming from seal team to udt
because there were so many new people
and so many i mean everybody was an e3
right because they expanded the teams
and same with the boat guys and
there was no time for training they just
wanted to get you into the war because
there was 500 000
americans in vietnam at the time so
you had to go over there and take the
next team's you know place i mean
how long was it from when you graduated
udt replacement training to
getting to the team how long did you
spend there before you went to vietnam
did you go to vietnam as a platoon no as
a team
as a whole team yeah as a whole team so
udt13 how many guys were there a
total of about 90 90 to 100.
and you're broken up into platoons
inside the team just like us of course
same basic so you all got on a plane
we uh we got on two planes we got on two
dc sixes
and we hedgehopped hawaii johnson island
uh you know going over it's a three-day
airplane ride
and because we just went from island to
island and finally made
it to p.i which was our main mustering
uh base and then we were dispatched to
where we were going to go and from
vietnam from there
but prior to prior to going on that
getting on that plane with the rest of
the team
did you go to desert warfare training
did you go to
did you guys train over the beach did
you guys just do hydro
hydro recons up at camp pendleton like
what did you do to get ready
yeah we did some of that but it was like
for for me it was like a month long
other guys who had been on a team for a
long time got that training because they
were there
i wasn't there and we were short manned
you know
because they just built that team so
they were drawing
and the beauty of team 13 and god rest
their souls to some of the people who've
been in it but a lot of times if you
wanted to get rid of somebody that was
causing a problem you'd send them to 13
right
lucky 13. yeah so it was a very
uh esoteric bunch of folks and uh
13 and a lot of characters you know what
i'm saying
so what platoon were you in at udt 13. i
think i was in bravo
and so it worked out good and paul plums
my oac
so you get on the plane now you're
flying over there you do you know what
your missions are going to be
don't have any idea don't have a clue
no idea what you're gonna be doing don't
know don't care just
give me the gun let's go are you have
you uh you know at one point you were
trying to avoid the draft but now you
seems like you're kind of all in let's
go get some
no but the reason people were avoiding
the draft because this army was so
pitiful because they were wasting those
bodies
why go i mean i don't mind dying right
because i never
i never thought i'd last past 29 i mean
i thought if i made it to 30 i'd be an
old man
i just had that feeling all my life yeah
and so but why waste your life
have somebody pour all that money to
bring you up and just kill you for no
reason
why do that but you're in the teams you
know the first day i got to the teams
we the first muster in the morning at
money
i looked at my right and i looked to my
left and it was all a bunch of weirdos
like me
i knew i never fit into society i wasn't
a popular guy or an
outgoing guy or a well-spoken guy i was
kind of
you know nobody really wanted me type of
guy you know what i'm saying
and so i get there and i see
in my class of 43 or whatever it was
people
they're all like me i said man i found a
home this is my
this is my people huh i mean
all a bunch of other weirdos
[Laughter]
and so now you're go now you get to
vietnam you have no idea what kind of
mission you're going to be doing
well we knew more or less because we
practiced it you know especially
in training training was built around
the mission
in vietnam so we did a lot of
hydrographic
reconnaissance we did a lot of
patrolling we did a lot of that
so we could pick up those skills you
know but we were the last class to go
into 13 so we didn't have the training
that they had before that when they
built the team and some of those guys
i mean they had been to vietnam like i
don't know if
you know you wouldn't know tobacco lou
this guy was fabulous and he was my
mentor
and he was just as crazy as a day long
but whenever he said something you
listened to him
because he had been in the vietnam a
number of times and he knew what he was
talking about
so you listen to the voice of authority
so that's what we all did lou said it we
did it
so you're training for hydrographic
reconnaissance
you're training for patrolling yep
and you're thinking that ea patrolling
oh for direct action
absolutely yeah so there's there's a
decent amount of crossover with what the
sealed
platoons were doing yeah we were the
poor man seals
so when they didn't have a mission they
didn't like you know give it to udt
so you show up in vietnam where where
did you initially go
tons of nuke then we got on the um oh i
can't remember the name of the ship
it was a destroyer escort and we did a
couple of months of
hydrographic reconnaissance and that was
that was really a good thing for us
because
uh we got to jail as a platoon
and everybody learned their place and we
saw who the real warriors were and who
to talk to and who to listen
and so that was very good and so like
after the mission you know in a debrief
lou would say things you know posey what
the hell is wrong with you
what you're standing at the beach party
and
you're lollygagging and not looking
around and not at the ready position
if the vc come over that berm what are
you going to do now you're right
i was you know and so he would
straighten us out he was a great mentor
to us because he'd been in seal team and
a stone alcoholic
but you know he would you you listen to
what he said
was he your platoon chief yes
and you guys are doing hydrographic
reconnaissance
are you lead line in slate whole nine
yards right
lead lining so i'll just explain because
nobody knows what a hydrographic
reconnaissance
so you have a beach party of four people
and so you have
two uh ends of it and in the center
and you have a line that could be at
least a thousand yards long and you have
it on a big spool
and so you take the spool and then
every depending on the gradient of the
beach every 50 feet or 100 feet you
would have somebody
swimming this line down the beach
and you might go a thousand yards you
might go you know a click
and you would take the
lead line see how deep it went and write
it on your slate
uh you know position number one 50 feet
position well you never went over 18
feet you know that was
18 to zero was what you're looking at in
hydrographic constants
then you would take all the slates once
you got done with your beach
and you'd go back to the ship and you'd
make a map of that
that beach so the gradient was at a
thousand yards out
it was 17 feet so if they have to bring
the lsts in or
landing craft they knew what was going
on
so it was very interesting and uh
really kind of a lot of fun because you
would just be you would have your face
in the water all day
you know just kicking and you usually do
two a day you do
a thousand yards in the morning maybe a
thousand yards in the afternoon
so it was a lot of fun and vietnam is
really a beautiful place
i mean breathtakingly beautiful and some
of the water
is just incredibly clear you know
especially camaron bay
just it's a delight to be in i mean it's
like being at a resort and getting paid
to be at the resort right
this is the promise you got yeah maybe
he's gonna be buying beer
were you guys doing mostly daytime or or
night time day time
because you had to see where you sat in
the line
and keep the line straight so
everybody's uh
slate would be correct yeah i did
two arg platoons yes back in the day and
we did hydrographic reconnaissance late
i remember we did a
ore operational readiness exercise
before we deployed to iraq
and my platoon drew the straw to get put
on the ship
for for the pre-deployment training
exercise and you know this is we know
we know like this is when you're in iraq
i'm getting ready to deploy to iraq we
know that we're going to take
those guys place right and we get put on
a ship
and we get we get this task and comes
down and i remember i walked down the
platoon space where all the guys are i'm
like
all right boys get the lead line and
slates out it's on
and one guy by the name of johnny i
won't say his full name
but he goes are you kidding me what are
we doing
we're going to do a hydro i said yep
we're doing a hydro i said he said you
got to be kidding me we're going to iraq
there are no freaking hydros in iraq 471
miles from the ocean yeah
he was going totally nuts and you know
what we did
we got our lead line and slate out and
we went out and did a hydrographic
reconnaissance with a flutter board at
red beach or whatever it wasn't
and took that stuff down that's that the
navy
still needed that information for
whatever reason i think now they're kind
of passed i think now they have
electronically yeah they can do it with
digital imagery and stuff like that but
that's only what 15 or 20 years ago that
we were still out there with a lead line
and a slate
[Laughter]
so that's your first couple months of
deployment you're just getting your
hydrographic reconnaissance on right
were you what was what position were you
the flutter board man because you were a
good swimmer
uh no i wasn't a good swimmer i mean i i
can swim okay but i wasn't the best
my position a lot of times we learned
then how to adapt
and we had an ibs on board the ship and
we put
the 9.9 horsepower motor on the back of
that ibs
and we pulled the sea side of it
so the the ocean i mean the land side we
could pull that
line so much quicker by doing that
and so much more accurately and that's
what we did and i was
constantly trying to keep that outboard
motor running right so that worked out
well for our whole platoon
yeah that's a hell of a lot easier than
trying to swim that flutter board yeah
how so you did that for a couple months
you're out there doing these
hydrographic reconnaissance and what
came after that
then we went into the delta and we
were off of antoi and we'd take swift
boats
off of an lst off of an island in the
south of vietnam
and go in and do patrolling
and that was basically the next four
months we did a lot of patrolling and
you know tried to do some d.a and stuff
like that you know
so what what are these operations like
uh you go in you get dropped off by the
swift boat
well first of all you go in this a lot
of very narrow uh
canals a lot of times if you weren't in
the river so you would always
engage at the beginning so you you knew
where exactly where they were going to
hit you so
you say okay at the point uh x-rays
coming up
everybody could get behind we had a
railing
and we had uh armor body armor on the
railing you know
and so we would all get behind the body
armor on the railing
and they would open up with an rpg or a
claymore or something like that
and we would go a mile past and said oh
that wasn't that bad today
you know so you you is it because you
were going through channelized areas and
you look at the map and be like oh yeah
here's the channelized area here's where
they're going to get us
yeah and so i mean it was very
ineffective but
you just kept your head down no swift
boat guys i mean they were always being
hit those guys were really
brave guys because they had so many
casualties and they were right there
you know with the 50s and the 60s and
stuff
and letting them have it where we'd be
hiding behind it
with our our m16 pointed out from the
side
okay we're going to we're going to get
those vc today we never saw
i'm sure they were on the other canal uh
you know with a command detonated
claymore or something you know
yeah what was the goal of these missions
um i i think just to
go make sure that they didn't take a big
foothold in whatever sector you were in
and we would go to their camp and we
would burn the camp down
and we'd get some c4 and light it and
put it in the hooches and it would burn
down their
hooches and we'd go run their pigs off
and stuff like that
and then we would patrol through the
jungle they'd drop us off in the jungle
and we'd put patrol through the jungle
because they weren't expecting us
you know at that time
that was right after tet so tet
in the united states was very
demoralizing because
the army always said you know we have
this
we have this sector we have this country
we're doing
better every day and then ted happens
this
massive battle and we beat him back of
course
but a lot especially the marines up
north really took a beating
and after that as far as the
people here in america i i think were
that that was the end of vietnam
we knew we were coming back out of
vietnam because they did tet
and then you go overseas and vietnam and
the army didn't want to go
they would tell us all the time they
would say okay you guys can go
outside the wire and do your mission or
whatever you want to do but don't expect
us to come
and you know be a qrf because we're
probably not coming out to get you or if
we're due it might be the night
next day right because the war
everybody wanted to stay behind the wire
because they knew the war was going to
be over
and they didn't want to be the last man
standing
so it was a different attitude but we
were gung-ho we went
hey let's rock and roll baby let's do it
you know
let's go this is our big chance and so
we we would go out and our officers were
very aggressive
the men were aggressive and we just
could do whatever we wanted to do
of course we ranted up the pole so that
the command knew what we were doing
but it was really good for us because we
could catch the vc
they'd be sitting lollygagging and we'd
be walking up to them
and they're over there lollygagging and
wouldn't have any idea that we were
coming on them you know
nobody was out there what position did
you walk in patrol
uh i was rear security so i like that
position
because a lot of in my estimation i'm
probably wrong here
but i was you know i was always
cognizant if somebody comes up on you
they're gonna usually see
you before you see them so you got to do
a good job
because it could be devastating them
coming right up you know right up on you
would most of your patrol how many guys
would you take out on a standard patrol
usually eight to ten would you guys
how many uh m60s would you carry and
would you got did you guys have stoners
like they had over on the steel team no
we were the poor man sealed so no
stoners
i'm just in going to talk about the m16
if you don't mind commander
you know we got to vietnam and we used a
variety of different weapons here in
training
in san diego and none
i don't remember any m-16s that we used
here so we get there and they give us
the m16
say man this is so much different from
those wood stock
very very heavy weapons we had you know
and they
they really work good and they're brand
new right
right out of cosmoline right and so we
go on our first
first mission and we get everything
we're soaked we're everything
because we're trooping through the
jungle and it's raining and we have to
go through these
different low spots they're full of
water and we get the gun wet
and we get in a fire fight and you
have to constantly recharge the weapon
because it wouldn't
it wouldn't work you know and so
we then we they had this real thick
lubricant that came from the
manufacturer of the weapon and he said
this is the
lubricant to use to keep your rifle but
it kind of gummed everything up
and so you know after about three of
these where the
thing didn't work i went to the armor i
said dude you got to give me something
that works
i don't care what it is you can give me
a six gun because it's better than an
m16 i can
i can make it work right and so they
give me an m3a1 a grease gun
you know a little tank uh people and
tanks and world war ii uses cost
general motors made these 12 these um
guns for 12
and 87 cents each during world war ii
right
and they gave me that gun the only thing
you have to do is shake it one time the
water out
and then that thing would work
flawlessly you could come
right out of the water bring it up give
it a little dip
bang bang bang bang it was a wonderful
weapon and i
i carried that a lot because it worked
every time
so i really like that weapon you know it
was very negatively buoyant but
it really worked good what was your op
tempo like i mean how often were you
guys going out on these patrols
you know sometimes a lot sometimes a
little
depending on what was going on and what
we had
coming down the pipe uh you know what
the navy would task us we were really
some a lot of times dependent on the
navy to do something with assets
swift boats or whatever so sometimes
we'd work five days a week sometimes six
sometimes two so
that's going to lead me to my next point
if you don't mind so i like to operate
right
you know and i i like to be busy because
i don't like to sit around
so i would volunteer i'd go to mr plum
and say mr plum you got to give me a job
man i can't sit here in this lst or
where on seafloat
you know we're on it's nasty and so
he said posey i got a deal for you
you're going to go with the army today
fine so what we would do
i would hook up with a second lieutenant
i was 21 at the time
and he was like 20 right never been in
combat and
they given him a platoon of arvin right
we had a platoon of 30 arvin
which was the vietnamese national guard
30 vietnamese
who had little battle experience if any
and we would go out with them and we
would patrol with these guys
and we never let them let them get
behind us
never ever let them get behind us
because you don't know
who's the vc and who's not and you'd get
shot in the back
so i would carry the radio they never
let non-english speaking people carry
the radio
because you had to have somebody you
know that people could one understand
too
knew that they weren't getting suckered
in with some viet cong
on the radio so i would carry the radio
and the lieutenant would be in front of
me and we would be in back of the
platoon
and so i really i like that because uh
i mean these guys were slow and they had
no ability to engage the enemy i mean
we had 30 guys and if there were six
guys engaging us you know they were
freaking out you know
and so we would kind of round them up
and you know oh you're going to go here
and you're going to go here and
you know it was kind of fun and
one day we were out there with these
guys and they all gave them
you know they knew there was no vc in
the vicinity
so that's the the missions that they
would give us because these guys were
so terrible and so we went out today and
we
we saw like these 30 guys giving us the
evil eye
about uh you know half a click off over
the other side of this rice paddy said
lt
we got to make it back to the the boats
because
these guys got that evil look on us and
they're going to come and get us and he
said yeah
so anyhow we're getting these you know
we're telling these visas i mean these
uh arvin guys we got to move we got to
get back well they're kind of
lollygagging along and these feces are
coming
right up on us right and i say to lt we
better
you know you know we better do something
he said oh know he he was good
i can't find fault with him at all so we
had this
this battle line there in the in the
head grove
area type and things got real bad for us
and so i got on the radio and i called
the net there and i said you know to the
army guys is there anybody else that can
come and help us do you have any helos
or anything out there that can help us
and they said we got no helos but we do
have a fast mover coming in
on you guys uh will that help you i said
does he have anything on board that can
light these guys up he said oh yeah he's
equipped with napalm
he said really and so
through that radio relay you know we
talked to that guy
and uh they talked to him i talked to
them and i said okay we're gonna pop the
smoke
and on the south side of the smoke don't
let that napalm go on us
you know let it go on those dudes and
they did and
i i'd never been around napalm close
before because you could always see it
in the distance but never close
and man that it was incredible the power
of the napalm
just absolutely incredible and hot we
were probably
100 feet away you know hunkered down we
could
we could see him off flying that phantom
coming in
and he dropped that napalm and it was
just like a blast furnace
and he lit those guys up and
the vc it lit them up and they were
still running
completely engulfed in flames and and
liquefied
their jelly gasoline and it was really
incredible to see that the power of that
weapon
and so then we obviously as soon as he
lit him up we all ran away
and went back to the extraction point
and so
i'm happy that guy was there because i
don't know it'd probably be me and the
lt
and the arvins at that point we'd let
the arvins been behind us because we had
been running full speed ahead through
that jungle right
i mean it was getting real bad real fast
how often would you say you came into
enemy contact on these operations you
know i've got some
some vietnam friends that that were in
the seal teams
sometimes they'd say they'd barely
gotten any contacts with the enemy
other guys different deployments they
got in contact even roger hayden from
one deployment to the next one time he's
out there it's like not too bad the next
time it's crazy
what was it like for you no it wasn't we
weren't seals and we knew we weren't
seals
and we would just go do the missions
that the navy told us to do
so it wasn't like ramadi i mean it was
we'd have contact as far as claymores
and stuff like that going on in swift
boats
but i mean it wasn't at all like
what you experienced in in your battles
well i don't know i didn't it wasn't
getting chased out by vc and having to
drop napalm
150 feet away but we were lucky on that
though you know
we were very lucky how were you how was
your luck with taking casualties
uh for the arvin no for for your seal
for your udt well in my platoon
i don't think we had one casualty and
we had a real good oic paul plum i don't
know if you know him
he was really a good officer and he
really looked out for the sailors
so we were really good with that and he
did
you know he would see the mission and he
would
explain the mission and very you know
most of the guys
we were called knuckle draggers right
and so
yeah yeah you had to be simple because
you know we just didn't have the
experience of
all the stuff that they have now and so
he was
really good and and we got it and
so it just wasn't the op tempo
of seal team one for udt in most places
and then how long will you do it yeah
this was all taking place
all those missions were taking place
those patrolling missions were taking
place out of the
the barge some would barge some of the
swift boat depending if you were an anne
toy and toy was a island and you'd go in
and the barge was in the middle of the
the river
you know and so we would deploy off of
that and so you did operations off
both those yes sir and how long were you
doing those types of operations so you
did a couple months worth of
hydrographic reconnaissance
off of the uss whatever that ship was
yes
and then and then now you're doing uss
cook uss cook
and now you're doing these type of
patrolling operations and
you know swift boat operations how many
months were you doing that for
i think around four but yet every two
months you'd have a break and sometimes
you go back to the pi
and regroup and get new guys or do
whatever
and then how long was the total
deployment uh six months okay so that
was
that was pretty much your deployment yes
sir
so you come home from that deployment
what year is it 69
yeah i think 69. and then what what was
the
what was the apollo oh that's right so
at what point did you hear about apollo
well when we were getting you know
nobody wanted to come home
at least most of the guys didn't want to
come home because
people didn't like you if you're in the
armed services if you had a haircut
like the most of us in this room they
perceived you to be a soldier or a
sailor and they didn't like you so
i didn't want to come home i volunteered
to stay
and then they said well you can go on
apollo i said no man i was a history
major
also in school and i said man this is a
time to you know if i can be on apollo
even though it's such a pain there's a
pain in the ass
that i should do this so they they one
day they announce okay we're going to do
apollo
12 and 13 and whoever wants to do it
come and see the xo
so nobody saw him the first day and so
the second day they made a quarters they
said
whoever wants to be on apollo
go see the xo because we knew the next
day you would be voluntold right
yeah and so for apollo 11 the first one
you were in vietnam when that only
happened right
we didn't even know what happened
because we were out and there was no tv
or radio
but that was the big one everybody
wanted to go on that one
i knew a couple guys on that and that
was really wolfram
i can't remember his first name but he
did a really good job on that
they had the good guys but then once it
was over people like ah
everyone here's what the story is it's
sitting around in the ocean for a while
looking up at the sky waiting for these
guys to touch down
being on a ship wherever you are so it
turned from a good deal to
like hey maybe we don't want it it
wasn't a team deal
right i mean it wasn't a good deal for
the team guys
so they say so i go to the exo and i
said okay
i want to go on apollo but i want to
choose my position on the team
and he says well what position do you
want to be and i said i want to be the
first man out the door
he says you got it posey so
he was lying to me and i know he was
lying to me but
i thought i had a shot right because the
first man out the team
had his name announced it was a
literally a billion people
looking at tv and even on the second one
because they thought the second one was
going to blow up because it got struck
by lightning on the path
right and so
so i said okay i'm going to be the first
guy out the door and he says yeah
and so then other people volunteered and
we
we did it so it the reason why it was a
pain
but is because we did it three times a
day morning
noon and night cover of darkness
is because we never knew when the
capsule was going to come down for sure
or not
right and you'd go out and in the first
supposed two hours
you'd be on scuba on the surface of the
water
because they thought there were moon
bugs we didn't know if there was
decontamination from the moon
excuse me and so you'd suck that thing
i mean i probably sucked that tank dry
in 15 minutes
but you had to keep it in your mouth on
the side to breathe because
you know that was the procedure that's
what nasa required
and so we would be out there and doing
this thing and
for the first two hours being on the
surface like that with that thing in
your mouth
it would make you seasick and so you'd
throw up
so every all the time before the mission
i would go eat a bunch of saltine
crackers
because i didn't like dry heaven i'd
rather heave something that was
solid rather than just dry heaving and
so you'd be seasick for maybe a half
hour then you'd get over it and
you know where you went and the process
for every minute they had you were
supposed to do
minute a minute b minute all the way to
xxxx
nasa knew what you were supposed to be
doing over that four hours and 45
minutes
and you had to abide by that schedule
to do because if you fell behind they
were really mad for whatever reason
and our team was really good and i think
we at one time we held the
recovery rector on apollotel for doing
the fastest one
and the problem with it is
the guys land in the ocean these three
astronauts in this capsule that's 12
feet across
and probably 10 feet oh not even 10 feet
9 feet high
right and they're bobbing there for like
an
hour on the thing inside of this capsule
on their back
and they come out and there is green i
mean i don't see anything green on this
table
they're this color green when they get
out of the capsule because they're so
seasick
because they've been in this capsule
with bad air and i'm sure all their
sewage problems and all this stuff and
they're green when they come
out of it and you want to get them out
of that as soon as possible so
you know to to give them some relief
so it was a very interesting thing
we had a mock-up and we practiced on
that off of the hornet that was the
aircraft carrier
we did that three times a day one time
we couldn't stop the capsule and the
capsule would
catch the wind and it would run if you
got in front of the capsule
it would run you over just like a
lawnmower right and go over you about
two knots and you know you can't swim
too much it's impossible
you know with all the stuff we had to
wear it's impossible at two knots
and so we couldn't stop this so we in
our morning exercise we couldn't stop it
so we went back in the afternoon
and i said you know if i get if you drop
me
right on the capsule i think because the
first man out the door
there was a d-ring on the side of the
capsule and you would hook this hook
into the d-ring and deploy a parachute
to stop the forward
progress of this capsule from running
over you and
running away he couldn't stop it so i
said drop me
right on the capsule and i can stop this
thing because we had the other team
doing it
and i was lucky enough to be able to do
it i'm sure the wind wasn't as great as
it was in the morning or whatever you
know
and they said because they were thinking
about firing a uh
a 50 caliber into it to sink it because
it's a navigation hazard
i mean it's a big piece of iron right
and we stopped that and then
on the mission day the seas from trough
to
crest to the wave were probably 12 to 15
feet
yeah it was really brutal and it was
slapping that capsule around like there
was no
end he said what are those guys going
through inside of that capsule
so i jump out of the helicopter that day
and they
they may put me right next to it right
and
i go and i can't find the d-ring i can't
find i'm panicked
you know what what to my mind commander
what's worse
being somewhere where you're supposed to
be competent and you're totally
incompetent
and you make a fool of yourself what's
worse than that nothing nothing
nothing you know it's like you know
especially with a billion people
watching yeah
that's that's the one thing that's worse
is have a billion people watch you be
being confident when you're supposed to
be confident it's like the bridegroom on
the
wedding night i mean you want to be
confident right you know what i'm saying
yes yes you want to be competent and so
i couldn't find it and i was panicked
and i didn't know
they put a piece of foil over because
the outer
layer of the capsule has foil it's gold
foil it's very bright
and it shined in your mask and it was
very difficult to see
so i'm going around tapping the sides of
the capsule looking for it i finally
found it
and i was able to hook it up and then we
went from there and so
it went really good for having such high
seas
so the rest of the process and they said
whatever you do
whatever you do you do not
go and strip the foil off the capsule
because they want to analyze its
capsules like a fiberglass aircraft
aluminum right
and all over the they have this gold
foil this plastic
gold foil do not take any of the foil
because we have to analyze the situation
when it comes out of the spa
out of the out of the air we need to
know what's going on
so oh no we would never do that right we
would never do that
so we knew at what point the aircraft
carrier the aircraft carrier takes four
miles to turn around right
and otherwise they're right on you and
they got the big you know the giant
binoculars about that big and they're
looking at you
you know uh you know one of those it's a
nasa guy's always hated us
just like everybody else and so
as soon as the aircraft carrier starts
making its turn we go on the other side
of the capsule and we're stripping this
foil off
and we're sticking it in our wetsuits
you know
what if we can sell it back to them yeah
one for mom one for the girl i had a
girlfriend that played the cello
and i could never get anywhere with that
girlfriend i said man this is
this is gonna bode me well with this
girlfriend this thing's been to the moon
man she's getting something what is this
[Laughter]
how big was the area that you knew that
the capsule was going to touch down in
well we anticipated being within four
miles so it was pretty accurate
pretty accurate but you never know
because they had the aircraft
i mean excuse me the air force guys and
c-130s
with the para paraguays being able to
jump out if it wasn't within
uh because they knew once it started
decelerating
coming out of space because it had to go
from 24
500 miles down to you know
five miles an hour uh they knew upon a
deceleration where it's going to be so
we would steam to that thing
and it i mean that that carrier was
right there
i mean we saw it come right out of the
sky so that was
really that that those mathematicians
and the sailors really did
did well on that yeah that seems like
that seems like a big challenge knowing
where that thing's going to be within
four miles free going from 25 000 miles
an hour
through through the atmosphere and then
did the did so were you the first guy
out you were the first guy out to did
they say your name on absolutely
there we go and so this is kind of a
funny funny thing here
so my mother was really proud of me you
know my
son he's going to be a mom nobody wanted
to do it
i volunteered first
[Laughter]
i you know she said don't tell the
neighbors that you are selected
as far as mom was concerned you went
through a rigorous selection program
to figure out who had who had the right
stuff that's right
now we we drew straws and the low man
got to go on apollo because nobody else
wanted
do you still have any of the foil no
dang it
uh so my mother knew i was going to be
in apollo and
she knew that my name was going to be
announced right and my city
so she we didn't have color tv my father
didn't like color tv so she says i'm
buying a color tv
i'm going to see my son so they had all
the neighbors in
and all the we had a group of kids that
i went to school and
college with and they all came over my
house and my wife
didn't know me but she came to my
mother's house just for that thing and
and she says my first time i saw my
husband was a half
inch tall
[Laughter]
so that was a big deal
so what happens when you get done with
that what's your next thing uh
i i wanted to go on 13 because
i just i was you know we my team was
really good at this
okay we had some great officers great
chiefs
great people doing it and i wanted to go
and i said okay i want to go
they said well you're just about done
and i said what do you mean i'm done
and he says well you got to sign up for
another four years
uh to go on this and i said four years
to go on apollo
uh because they had the vietnamization
this was terrible thing and this is what
i see going on in iraq
they had the vietnamization of vietnam
so we turned over all of our assets to
the vietnamese
especially in the very hot sectors
and we would only go as backup or
support if they were
having a problem you know and so you
could see the end of the war coming
even in 69 the end of the war was coming
because
these guys were taken over they were
completely incompetent
and so i said man of this team 13 going
to make another deployment
probably you know but what's it going to
be like are we just going to be sitting
you know watching victory at sea movies
somewhere and not really going out and
doing a lot
and so i i just got out i didn't up for
that other four years
so did you stay in the reserves was
there a reserve
at the time uh the navy the real navy
reserves
so just big navy reserves big navy
reserve and you went to a diving unit or
something
and then is that is that what you did
you stayed in the reserves and then
they uh admiral bonnelli was
instrumental in getting
the other the udt udt seal reserves
going
so then when they did that i joined that
but then
i got real busy and i dropped out of
that for a while what did you do when
you
when when you were in the reserves and
now you're re-entering the civilian
world what did you do
uh school what'd you go to school for um
anything i can get as quick as possible
because i was 24 years old
and i wanted to get out of school
because my contemporaries were very
young
and i just wanted to get out so i went
i tried to jam through that as quick as
i could and what'd you get a degree in
history and then a minor in business and
and then what'd you do
um well one of the
actually before school started i
hitchhiked around the world
so at that time you could hitchhike
around the world and i wanted to see the
world and see what was going on you know
and so we started in la
and we got in those days you could get a
car
and if you drove it to new york they
would
pay for the gas so it was free because
we had only had twelve hundred dollars
to go around the world
uh it was a service instead of
transporting it they let people drive it
across
so it's like the early form of uber yeah
yeah
it was you drive uber right so we got in
this car
and this car was a brand new um
god what was it something british right
and it could go like an mg or something
no no it was better than mg
really i can't remember what it was but
it was small
but it was really triumph maybe it's
triumph
so no it was it was something pretty
nice
i can't imagine a worse decision than
someone getting
this is bad decision but no wonder this
kind of uber didn't work out
dude you ruined it so
we get this car on a like a friday
afternoon and you have to call the guy
and say okay we're leaving los angeles
right now
and we'll be there maybe tuesday or
wednesday right
so 49 hours later we get to new york
city
and we call the guy and he said hey
we're here he said you're here
49 hours to go 3000 miles
well we left we really left earlier than
friday right
and we were literally going a lot 100
miles an hour across the nation
and at that time you could really go
right and so
then we just got on airplane at that
time the cheapest airline was icelandic
airline but you had to spend
three days in iceland so that was cool
right who are you with
you oh my travel friend uh a
guy that i'd known for 10 years he was
really a great guy just another guy from
linwood that you grew up with yeah he
was really he's a big dude
and that worked out well for us because
hitchhiking could be a little iffy at
times
and then we got to
where we pulled wherever we pulled in
europe but they had a real late winter
and we didn't have any winter clothes so
we only stayed in europe like a month
and then we went down to we went down to
uh israel and if you wanted to work in
israel
so we went and got a job at a kaboots in
israel for three months
so that was really good what were you
doing there uh just working on this
caboots and i was a beekeeper and so
they made me a beekeepers
and then a painter and so we were doing
that and they paid us five dollars a
month
and free room and board but that was
cool because then we could see
all the sites in israel because i always
wanted to go to israel right
and pay and at that time you could
hitchhike all over israel anybody would
pick you up
and let's say you're going from haifa
where we were
down south to you know the dead sea or
whatever you could do that
it was really good and we left there and
just started hitchhiking across the
world
is this like 1970 or so uh 71 yeah
71 i think yeah and
what's the when you're when you're home
from vietnam
and you know you're talking about
earlier you know people are
they think you're a soldier they're
looking down and you did you feel that
once you're right back
absolutely i mean i i really had regret
that i didn't stay in the military
because
uh you know the people wouldn't have
anything to do with you of course as
soon as you got out you let your hair
grow a little longer
you know and so that you fit in more
rather than
you know not having any hair so that
kind of mask what was going on
but i mean the you know the hippies were
just
plain you know nasty i mean they
the thing i hated about them they had
dirty knees and dirty elbows
they didn't take shower all the time and
they stunk and they smelled like
marijuana i mean it was really nasty
you know when the women were i mean they
didn't keep themselves up it was
it was bad so i had no inkling there
that i wanted to be a hippie
i just didn't i don't get any inkling
that you were much of anything either
nobody wanted to be a well none of my
elf wanted to be a hippie
right so so you how long did this uh
did this hitchhiking scenario last about
10 months
took us 10 months to go around the world
did you keep going
did you keep heading east after you got
to israel oh yeah we hitchhiked across
well that time you couldn't go to an
arab country after israel
so you had to go to cyprus then from
cyprus to turkey then we just started
hitchhiking in turkey
and made it across afghanistan and then
through india you know and we could make
it to bangladesh well
bangladesh was east pakistan at the time
they didn't have bangladesh because a
lot of countries changed
you know since then and we made it there
then we had to get on a
aircraft because we couldn't go across
burma
and you know go we did go to burma spent
a couple of days there
then to japan and back to the states
sometimes you either had to fly or be on
a ship because you can't hitchhike in
the water right
and did you feel like at the end at the
end of that that you had
sort of gotten your fill of and seeing
what you wanted to see
yeah and for that sector yeah but
you know i really i always we did a
westpac
you know with uh uh udt so we saw
you know china which is hong kong at the
time in japan and stuff so
you know but then the next year i went
to school and then we took the summer
off we got student loans to travel in
the summer not to
go through school because we had a gi
bill right and so
got student loans and we hitchhiked to
chile and came back with a three-month
period
so that was good what are you doing on
the when you're in chile what are you
doing
for instance we're just hitchhiking and
seeing what's going on with the people
you know because then you travel with
the people and you really see what's
going on
you really see rather than being on an
airplane you see their mode of
transportation what they eat and
you know we never had a problem
never had a problem you said you did a
westpac with udt when was the westpac
no that was during vietnam i mean that
was called the westpac got it
right yeah and being on board ship for
that two months
we did sailing too so then
you do this trip now now you get back to
california
yeah and now you gotta like grow up kind
of well
no then it was then i had a very serious
major in college
it was beer and women and so
i was i excelled
where'd you go to college when you got
back uh orange coast college in
uh orange county and you continued to
study history
is that what you started yeah because it
was the quickest way of getting out of
college and you just wanted to get out
and get some kind of a job just wanted
to rock and roll that's right
just go get some kind of work so i could
make money
then what was it two years did you
finish college no it was actually
what i had to start over because i took
a lot of stuff that wouldn't transfer
to an academic major because i took a
practical art
with auto mechanics but then it took me
like a year and a half to get out of
junior college in another
year and a half to get out of you know
big boy college
and then what then i went to work i went
to work for
machinery manufacturer then i got back
into the reserves
what year did you get back in the
reserves oh geez
maybe 75 i think they
you know i told you earlier that i had
covet real bad
and i lost part of my memory so i i have
hard time with dates and names i just
can't remember what it was
i mean that's might not have anything to
do with cove but it might do the fact
that it's 40 something years ago and you
didn't really care at the time i'm going
back in the reserves whatever
yeah it's funny i find myself i can't
remember sometimes what platoons i was
in because people like i didn't split
through this with you i'm like
what platoon was that i kind of forget
sometimes when
it's like your whole life for a year and
a half as your platoon and i'm like what
kind of idiot am i that i don't remember
what platoon i was at
i can usually back but uh deconstruct
what it was and figure it out
so you go back in the reserves and but
you when you're back in the reserves are
you part of the udt reserves yes
they started it then whenever that was
and then and then what are you doing one
weekend a month yeah
and you're going down and drinking beer
and doing beach reconnaissance
no no i mean it actually looked udt
really cleaned up because then they saw
what seal team did that cut the way for
us
so we would do more sealed team things
than we would do udt because udt was a
thing of the past
so that was really good and so we did
that i did that and then
you know i don't know how many years i
did that
and i got out for a while then i came
back in like
86 and
came back in the reserves and uh
then you know it was it was you know
that was really good
and then the i know in that book
uh naval mentioned that in the fir when
the first gulf war kicked off
yeah you rogered up said hey send me
what happened with that
well i got um
i wasn't fully qualified on a couple of
things
and so they wouldn't send me and so you
know that was cool and that just made me
work harder to get up to speed on
everything
so it just didn't work out
but you know what can you do i mean if
you're not
if you don't have those calls you don't
have those questions what calls didn't
you have like dive soup or something or
yeah
just like the standard kind of seal yeah
just stuff like that because i got in a
year before
but i i kind of evolved i was 40 years
old i
think at the time i can't remember how
old i was
and you know you're not going to run and
gun
like these studly dudes right here right
you're not going to do it because
you can't do it right no matter how much
you work out or
you know and so i said you know
i really have to find my place and see
where i'm an
asset and so the training department was
really good for me because there was a
big
paper pushed there and i got to work in
training
and then i got to go to a lot of places
i could volunteer
i would volunteer for 30 to 60 days a
year
to go to exercises to support the teams
so that was
really good for me you know and so
i learned a lot because of that what do
you remember about
when you know udt 13 got decommissioned
and then udt 11 and 12 sunsetted and
became
seal team three and 18 five and 83. so
you were were you still in the reserves
at that time i wasn't in
and so that i did i missed that process
and then of course the funding and i
don't know because i wasn't there but
that's what i think happened
the funding process and the leadership
process went from the navy
from big navy to socom and so
i'm sure people listening to this that
live that
will find fault with me on my facts but
it was a different world
the navy you know this
team guys wear thin very quickly right
very we're out of welcoming wear it out
and you have to really protect yourself
against that because then the other
units won't
work with you and if they won't work
with you you can't do it by yourself
so yeah well we definitely learned that
lesson over time of
you know just getting to working with
your counterparts and
giving them the support that you can
give absolutely because then they'll
support you back
right so after the first gulf war where
you got denied
but then you realized all right i got to
figure out how i can help what i can do
and you stay in the reserves for the
next
10 years and then september 11th happens
yes
where where were you at september
september 11th
uh september i was actually going to go
to work
for uh the boats and help
promote their recruiting okay and so
uh that was on the 10th of december
i mean 10th of september and so i was
going to go work with them
like at a dod job to help promote that
or be an
active reservist they hadn't worked it
out so
then they said on the 10th they said
don't calm down because we're not using
it we'll give you a call the next week
tell you because we don't have your
funding appropriated yet
and so on the 11th my friend calls me
and he says have you watched the tv and
i'd worked all night because i was doing
i was flipping houses right
and i worked out all night on this one
property and i went home
and he calls me at eight o'clock in the
morning says you seen the tv and i said
no
he says get down and watch a tv so then
that's with the towers he said
so i called the unit and i said hey
i'm available what's going on don't come
because the base was were you in at that
time commander i was
i was actually going to college the navy
had me in college at that time and i was
doing the same thing
i was calling my detailer and saying hey
sir
i'll quit college right now i'll finish
this stuff later i don't care
and you know i had this conversation
with him it was it was admiral pibas
and he i had worked for him before and
he was an
awesome boss and when september 11th
happened i called him
and said hey i'll do anything you know
send me back to seal team i don't need
my degree i'll do my degree online
whatever and what's cool is you know i
think i'm
you know being all default aggressive
and stuff but i talked to him
a couple of years ago actually i talked
to him and his wife and guess what
every guy that wasn't at a team was
calling up saying
hey i'm ready to go i'm ready to go
that's that's the community
it's everyone wanted to get
to go fight that's what we do the world
war ii guys are calling
yeah exactly exactly
yeah so you call up and you say
and what they tell you they say
don't come to basis lockdown but come
because they could activate me on
reservist orders and because i knew it
was going to happen because
we had some of those same problems in
vietnam here
and so i'm good at making little things
happen
and so they i went down there i think on
a friday i think
the 911 was on a tuesday i just can't
remember
and so then i went down there that
friday and then went to group one
and started working some issues that
they had especially activating
reservists
yeah because all of a sudden we needed
to manage all kinds of positions
a lot of positions and the teams guys
team
positions that team guys didn't want to
do and rightfully so but it was good
to get the reservists back in to that
line of fire
so that they could you know because you
you know you got to get it on
you know i mean it takes a while to get
up to speed
the war kicks off in afghanistan at what
point did you
did you get on the on the freaking
launch pad to go to iraq
uh how old were you at that point um
2003 is when you went no
uh i think i went
either 2002 or 2003 i can't remember but
before the war just before the war
started
so what happened is i'm there working
for group and i would
um a great guy that i
really really love jimmy bear and master
chief baron i don't know if you can
remember him sir
master chief baron was working on the
dpvs they actually pulled them out of
storage a dpv
is a dune buggy looking thing with the
is it a 50 or a 60 on the top i can't
remember
right i think it could be either one
yeah you could you could go either way
on that
like being oh i shouldn't say that
little joke but i would i'll refrain
there
[Laughter]
and so uh he pulled those out of storage
and he was
really good wrench turner i mean he was
fabulous he was a guru
and so i asked him i said you know i'm
here at group can i support you guys and
he says well
you can't do it during the day but you
can come at night and so
i went there a bit to help them
because they were trying to push that
stuff out the door before christmas
right and so uh
i go down there and i'm turning a wrench
in there at like three o'clock in the
morning
saying well it's about we have to be
back here at 6. it's about time we went
home you know
that type of thing baron is a great guy
in this whole
i think there was nine guys involved
with baron on those three or four
dpvs maybe it was more and so
i got to work with them because i wanted
to go forward right
so my boss at group one i said they had
as soon as we come on board they have a
thing in the conference room they said
okay who wants to go forward who wants
to go to the war
everybody raises their hand and
my my civilian boss he looks at me and
he says posey
he says you're too old you're too fat
you're too stupid you're the last guy
we're going to say
we're going to slim the cleaning lady
before we're going to send you i said no
you're not you're going to send me
he says no way in hell okay
and i said yeah you're going to send me
so he was why was i arguing with my boss
right to
have him do me a favor and send me
overseas right
who would do that i was stupid and so
so he was right yeah
[Laughter]
so he says he says no we got
a lot of work for you to do we got to
push all these guys out
because you know the the reserves at
that time
weren't really we had kind of a
looser type of reserve unit and they
weren't deployed that often
so some of them had id cards that
weren't current i mean there was
you know in their wills were from three
wives back
in 1972 you know and
you had to bring all that a mountain of
paperwork that usually took four or five
days
and we were trying to facilitate these
guys through this system
to get them out the door you know and to
get them you know just
basic training because we didn't do a
lot of chemical training basic chemical
training and all that kind of thing
so i was doing that and i was working
dpvs at night
and finally master chief baron leaves
the 20 i think it was the 26th of
december
and and so i said man
i was really hoping i could go with
those guys so
anyhow they have like a couple of weeks
later
they said we need somebody to go over uh
to um there to help service vehicles
on humvees because we never had a lot of
humvees we never had a lot of vehicles
and seal teams
especially there was no up armor no
armor and they were putting
humvees out of out of the surplus
storage
from the army i mean they were just
thrashed right
so i said you know i'm really good mckin
i didn't never i never opened a hood of
a humvee right
didn't have a clue i said i'm really a
good mechanic and
i think you should send me they're
looking at me that's 56 years old right
so eventually because they couldn't find
anybody better than me which was
the first rung of the ladder i mean they
said okay you're you're going you're
going
you're going over and you're going to
work on these humvees
i said well what are we going to do
about tools and they said well
baron has all the tools and he has all
the stuff but
everybody knows in any given wartime
situation
that you don't whatever you need the
most you never get
i mean if you need that special gun or
whatever it is it never
shows up right so i go to harbor freight
and i buy this gigantic
box of tools because i know that those
you know those assets aren't going to be
there and so i took my box of tools
and they they hadn't got their tools all
their tools and they're coming over
borrow
they had all snap on stuff you know with
the snap-on
shirt and you know the ten thousand
dollar box just the box alone was ten
thousand dollars
i got my harbor freight 298 a crescent
wrench right
and so oh posey could we we really need
a
a number 11 metric uh entrance you got
of course i got it
so they sent me over and they had these
uh
these uh hilux toyotas that they were
going to use
on the initial invasion and they put
winches and all kinds of different stuff
on them
but the hilux shows up but all the other
stuff's not put on so that was my
i think the first couple of weeks that i
was putting on all the stuff
to the hiluxes to get them out and then
we had a lot of servicing of humvees and
all that
and a lot of reorg stuff and so
then they were looking for people to go
forward who's going to go in this
position
me god come on come on we're scraping
the bottom of the barrel here
geez louise and so uh
so i'm stuck back at the base and i'm
doing different stuff that i really
don't like to do
and i'm listening you know to see when a
chance of me going forward what's what's
the need
what kind of talent that i have because
i think
most of us marine corps and different
facets of society we have a place in
society
like i'm not a leader at all i'm a
follower but i'm a real good follower
the command you know commander's intent
i want to hear the commander's intent
then i want to explore with the
commander what that intent is
i want to know what it really means
because sometimes the words don't convey
what that person really
thinks i want to know how i can support
that person
any way possible you know what's his
real meaning
what's those words coming out of his
mouth how can i help
if i can make my sailors
have whatever they need and they're
happy
and then secondary that if i can make my
boss look good
and then the navy look good then it's
cool right
yeah it's cool i mean everybody's cool
because that's they want you around then
if you get
they say well who did this and and
they say posey did it and so it was a
good thing right i mean
you know you did this right or whatever
and i said no no no
no it wasn't me it was my two
subordinate smuckitelli
and jira deli here so i always try to
defer that
or push it back to my boss because
that's what makes you valuable
and if you need a favor sometime those
people will come
forward and i learned that in vietnam
when we would go to these different
places
they would leave like flags and pictures
of
different things and china and pottery
then we were able to take those assets
to the guys that were on the navy bases
and if we needed
you know cases of sea rats at the time
or
would you guys mind you're unloading all
this beer out of this ship
and would you guys mind pushing a pallet
of this beer off the dock
and let it fall into the water and then
we'll retrieve it and i'll trade you
this vietcong flag with fat
genuine vietnam blood they didn't know
it's pig's blood
with a couple bullet holes that we shot
in the parking lot
we would really appreciate that you know
so we could barter our way
in vietnam because we had no money we
had no assets we could barter our way
uh into different things and then i knew
because so many people hadn't been to
the war
since vietnam well they did of course
they did the 96-hour war
and they did other little wars but they
didn't have a supply trade
i knew that i could be valuable there
securing assets
for my team we only had 44 guys
originally in
in baghdad
so before i went i i went on the
internet and i buy it
i should have bought 12. i bought six
iraqi flags
and i took them with me and then i took
uh 550 dollars of cash at small bills
and another 500 in large bills because i
knew that
as soon as we won that the
currency would be no longer valid and
that you could buy that currency at a
bargain rate
and be able to do something with that
currency right
and so when the war started i mean when
the war ended
as far as george bush calling it off
nobody knew what to do with the currency
so
before it was like a 16-1 ratio with
iraqi currency for the american dollar
and in in then by the time
bush called the war off it was in limbo
and you could do a thousand to one
you could literally buy i turned my 550
into rocky dinar and i could buy a box
of money
a box of money okay
and so but there was nothing to buy yeah
there's nothing to buy the
the sanctions really worked in iraq
there was nothing to buy
and so um i had all this money and
i had the i brought the flags and i was
trading because we don't have an
seal team when i got to iraq we don't
have a logistics tale
right at that time now we have a
logistics tail they got so much smarter
but we didn't i was the logistics tale
and
as soon as we get we we went uh
real quick so you weren't you were in
kuwait yes when you were preparing to go
yes they're saying hey we need someone
to so so the
troops push up into baghdad yes you're
still in kuwait right
finally they go look we need someone to
help us up there we got vehicles to
maintain we got to build a base
they're looking around they keep looking
past you and finally they freaking got
no choice but they said the old man up
there
to go get something i'm the last uh fish
in the barrel right
so what do you do jump on a hilo and fly
up to baghdad international airport
or did you drive up no no no so they
tell me they tell me
i i was in your team area in kuwait now
as a team you could hitchhike
real easy though it was really quick i
love hitchhiking because you meet a lot
of interesting people
but anyhow i have my own vehicle because
i'm the
like the uh the go-to
guy to get things done for whatever you
know little things you know somebody's
got this or
they need that or whatever so they tell
me it
five minutes after one in in kuwait they
said
you have to be at uh help me with the
name of the air base
uh you have to be at the al assad
uh by two o'clock and you're getting on
an airplane
and you're going to baghdad and they're
going to drop you off there at baghdad
you and barron i said dude it's five
minutes after one
and it's like 70 miles how in iraq
i mean in kuwait how the hell am i gonna
she says you've got to be there
get in your car and go shut up so i get
in my car and i got this rental car and
i'm going literally a hundred miles an
hour down
the iraqi i mean the kuwait freeway
luckily they didn't stop me
and i get there at 10 min no it's 12
minutes to two
and i tell baron baron get your stuff
and we're going to a wreck he said posey
what do you got me into
i said i got things going here i can't i
said
this i showed him the orders i had a set
of orders for him
he said oh my god you dumbass
and so we we throw all this stew i get
my toolbox and throw it in there
and i mean we're just jamming stuff in
this rental vehicle
and we get there we get to the
the c-130 at one minute to two
okay one minute to do and the guy's
looking at me the crew chiefs look at
him he said
what are you doing i said we got orders
here's our orders he said
yeah you got ours we know who you are
he's i said well what's going on let's
go
he says 0-200
0-200 too much time in the civilian
world for you
huh no but they told me two o'clock
no they said you got i mean oh my god so
we go back and we pack our stuff and we
actually put underwear in our in our sea
bag and the whole thing right
and so we're there and so we thought
we were going to go to biop right to
baghdad international saddam hussein
international airport right
and so these guys get us in there and
they
they go on the red light in in the
aircraft he said well what's going on
where are we going
he said well we're going to a road about
40 miles outside of
uh out of baghdad to meet your guys i
said really
and they have this pallet of stuff in
the aircraft
and i said okay sounds good we're going
in no lights no nothing we're going to
be on this highway outside of
baghdad right me and jimmy bear posey
i'm going to kick your ass
because the guy been to you know a ton
of stuff i mean he's
it's like talking to michael jordan
that's that's
master chief baron right i mean he's the
man right
the man and dumbass worn officer posey
telling him what to do so so we get
there and he says okay we're going down
we're going to go into this highway
we're going to turn around and we're
going to do a five and five
onion i said really i said you got this
you know i said okay well you're gonna
ride the pallet out right
i said okay good so we jump on this
pallet
well it wasn't a five and five they were
on actually on the deck
right and they let us out of this
aircraft and we're going about 20 miles
an hour but we just rode the pallet out
and our guys and we we have all this
ammunition and all this stuff that they
needed
and so uh
we we immediately head over to this
hedge and just sit there for about a
half hour
and our guys eventually uh they knew we
were there
but they were afraid that some you know
the iraqis were going to get on us
and so then we go the next day we go in
on these six buys to to baghdad
and we go along the road and people are
clapping
we love george bush we love george bush
really they love george bush i mean all
along the highway
they're telling us that i said my god i
should have took a picture of that
because
they didn't love us after a couple of
weeks right so we go to buy up there's
nobody there
so we go to owl lundy palace
no the first no i'm sorry we go to the
cia headquarters the iraqi ci
headquarters
and we're we're mustering there for a
day or two
so we get in there and what they did is
they used a j
dam and they collapsed the six story
iraqi cia headquarters
down they pancaked it down to two
two sections of the building that
survived
and so there was cordite and concrete
dust everywhere it was very hard to
breathe
and so we go in there and i said you
know we ought to go
uh we ought to go to uh these offices
the top offices should be a head dude in
the iraqi cia right
the the head guy has the top office we
have to go see
what we can see so we make our way
through all this
construction stuff destruction stuff and
we go to the top office and it's uday's
office
right and so i opened the desk drawer of
uday's office
and he's got these chrome
sunglasses that like elvis wore right
i said and the guy i was with
the chief that i was with he he grabs
his glasses
and then he had on his desk a picture of
him in these glasses
and so he grabs that and he says
okay which one do you want i said i'll
take the glasses
and he says okay so he takes the picture
and i i take the glasses so i got
today's glasses
so we stay there a couple of days and
then
i go out that morning that we're
supposed to leave because
i wanted to make sure the vehicle was
serviced and ready to go
because we had gasoline we had
ammunition we had mortars we had
all kinds of stuff on this six by truck
and i think we had three or four
vehicles so i'm up in the cab of this
truck making sure everything's on
and i have my bayonet that i had in
vietnam
and i'm sitting in the seat like this
and my bayonet gets stuck
in this mtvr truck there and then they
start shooting at me
uh you know and it's just i mean it's
five o'clock in the morning the sun just
come up and they're shooting at me right
say man i gotta get out of this truck
because it could go you know
if they hit the gasoline god knows
what's going on so i'm trying to get out
of this truck
and i'm trying to push this stupid
bayonet over to the side
and i'm pulling and pulling and i go out
the side of the truck and i didn't
see this culvert right here and i go
i do the big crash i got my weapon and
across my chest and my
battle rattle and man it's killing me
it's
killing me and so
uh i get out of there and i walk back to
there and you know whatever and we go
then we go to al
burundi palace and uh
we said well the army's going to come in
here to buy up and they're going to run
things they're the 800 pound gorilla
right
they're always the 800 pound gorilla no
matter where we go
we shouldn't this the commander is
making this decision
we should go find another place because
we don't want to get kicked out once we
start improving it
so we go down to the servants quarters
and they have some nice little buildings
there but they burn off
out some of the buildings and they stole
all the air conditioning and the wiring
in the walls and everything
and so we go in there and that's that's
our that's our
camp cheney posey right it wasn't jenny
posey at the time
and so we go there it's neptune trident
you know every seal team named it known
to men
so we start improving that camp because
we know we're going to have a lot of
people late on in that camp
you know just not the 18 that we
originally started with
so we go to this camp and we started
improving it and i don't know if you
know
uh ranger i don't want to say his last
year i know okay yeah
i'll call him ranger right and this guy
is a master i mean
so we're in biop and we're the only but
the only people in buy up and there's
some
little you know skirmishes and stuff out
of town but there's not a whole lot
going in
so we're going to biop and we're going
to the army and it's like being with us
a rock star people are saying
i mean he's driving this humvee right
john john we haven't seen you since
grenada
john we haven't seen you since panama
how you doing i mean the guy's a rock
star there
in the army right i said man i'm i'm
happy that i know this guy
and so we do that then people start
coming in and we had a real good op
tempo
to begin with seal team was really
kicking ass
okay we had great commanders great
platoon chiefs
i mean everybody i mean because we
thought the war might be a 96-hour war
like it was the first gulf war so we
want to get as much experience
as possible right little did we know
we'd be there 22 years later
21 years later so
so we're there improving the camp and
this and then
we're there one day and we have a
morning meeting at 8 o'clock with
everybody in the camp
and john comes in and he says
he's swearing and he never swore he
never swore and he swore he says
i'm so sick of this uh he tells the
commander right there
i'm so sick of this we're changing the
name of this camp
nobody knows where this camp we've
changed the name of this camp 15 times
since we've been there the army doesn't
know where
they changed the name you know we're
naming this camp
camp bill posey and
i look at him i said are you out of your
mind
are you out of your mind only dead
people
or very courageous people have a seal
a seal team camp named after him
are you crazy he says no we're doing
that we're announcing it at the mayor
the meeting tonight i said john don't
don't do that just
look just let me have time to think
about it so as soon as the army came in
they cut us off our up tempo
we had no operations going because they
were afraid of us right
they wanted to homogenize everything
and make everything happen the way they
want it to happen
and rightfully so because they're going
to swing it probably won't be us
right so i go to the morning meeting
the mayor's meeting and
i said hey i got some great news
we're going to rename our camp after an
army person because seal team has the
greatest respect
ever for the army and we love what you
guys are doing here
at biop and we think we want to honor
you
and people say posie what are you
talking about sit down you dumbass
i said no no we want to do this and they
said okay
no problem so i go back to my guys and i
say okay
let's name the camp i had to name it
after an army person right
and it was either audie murphy or my
daughter
who was a jrotc
at ucla ucla
yeah so we're going to name the camp
either audie murphy or
my daughter who's a rotc cadet i think
so he said okay we're gonna name it
after your daughter so we named the camp
camp jenny posey right so
that was very and i can't believe i mean
john coming in there and saying that
and people going along with it why would
he do that i just i never figured that
out but it worked and
and it it was really nice of him and
nice of the command to allow that to
happen
because i did not deserve it i'm not
mike monsewer or any of those other very
courageous
dudes and i wasn't dead yet so i thought
that might be some bad juju you know
what i'm saying
yeah it was it was awesome i ended up
spending six months at jenny posey
in 2003 2004 and
what was cool wasn't it there's a
classic picture of this and i'll find it
and get it posted somewhere but
the you know we go out do our operations
and we
could go out for however many hours or
days we'd be out
for and when you get back to camp there
was a big sign
on the camp door it was it was a pretty
good selection for the space because we
could come we could shut this big giant
gate and it would just be no there would
be no one on there but us
but on the you you guys made this big
giant sign that said welcome home
to camp jenny posey and it was just an
awesome sight when you come back no
matter what happened out there
you'd come back you'd see that big sign
and be like all right we're good to go
so that was uh that was that was the way
it should be and it's a pretty freaking
legendary situation to have
it was different so
how long did you end up staying there in
iraq
because you ended up did you end up
getting hurt something happened to you
well
when i jumped out of the truck i didn't
know it at the time but i broke my back
but you know i went to the army that day
when we pulled into buy-up and i said
man you guys got to give me something
because
my back is killing me and the guy says
okay let me examine you and so he says
you don't have a medical record so i got
an mre box and put
medical record bill posey here it is
here's my medical record right
and he says well i'm going to send you
back to germany and
uh i said no you're not you're not he
says yeah you got your medical record
here
and i'm going to send you back i took
that medical record and i walked out of
there
and he was lucky i got some pills some
pain pills before that so that knocked
it down
it wasn't you know it wasn't terribly
debilitating
so it it worked out
so did you roll out on any ops with the
boys
oh yeah i got to do 30 i think but you
know
being 56 years old of course you know
well grandpa is here and he he's gonna
you know he he doesn't have all of his
teeth but you know
but you know it's always in the c2 unit
you know in the back up so if something
happened at least we could get the
squirters
you know and all that and at least take
care of them
or if we had to you know go help those
guys in a qrf situation we were always
available you know
so that was good you know i really
enjoyed that i i really appreciate them
allowing me to do that i don't know if
i'd have been an asset or a deficit you
know
so well i can tell you the you know the
having the vehicles out there you never
know when something's going to
go wrong with the vehicle and to not
have a good
mechanic there to ready to get those
things up and running and like you said
those
those humvees that we had because we got
those humvees turned over to
us and we showed up a couple months
after you left
same those things were beat down
hand-me-downs
you know scavenge marine corps hand me
dance i believe they came out
from more some of them were see we got
some from some cb somewhere
we got some some reservists somewhere
canvas doors
i mean they were a total disaster but
you guys got them up and running and we
kept we know we kept working on them
and we know what was awesome was it
didn't take very long
like you said the seal teams not only
did we not have vehicles
but prior to this we didn't have any
vehicle procedures either we didn't
we didn't know anything we just we would
we actually thought that vehicles
it was kind of a joke in the seal teams
if you got inserted by a vehicle we'd
call it a
a helo truck right meaning hey we're
just pretending this is a helicopter we
don't really have one
we didn't realize like this is going to
be our primary mode of transportation is
going to be
the humvee not even the dpvs or any of
these high-speed vehicles
for a solid three years they're in the
middle it was a humvee and that was it
that's what you were getting
and not up armored oh yeah yeah not up
armored at least not in the beginning no
not in the beginning and we ended up
doing mad max kind of things we'd end up
with
finding this the the bulletproof steel
eventually we put that on various
parts of the humvee to try and protect
you as much as you could yeah the first
few months we were there
we we had turned the seats in the
humvees to face
outboard so that our our our body armor
would be facing outward and we could sit
there and scan
but i mean it was because we took the
canvas door what the canvas going to do
not going to do you any good at all and
so we we did what we could but we
but what was really impressive not only
do we get the vehicles up to speed and
then we were doing all like the
nascar drills of figuring out how to
change tires really quick and
rigging for tow all those things we
rigged all that stuff up
all the navigation systems which we got
from this the civilian sector
of of you know just taking a gps and
coupling it with a
with a portable computer and so we'd
have the live feed gps going in there
it's all stuff that we just figured out
and then
all the actual immediate action drills
we did all that within
a very short period of time because
and it's one of the one of the strong
points of the seal teams and one of the
weak points of the seal teams
one of the weak points of the steel
teams is we didn't really have any
standard operating procedures for a lot
of things there's no manual like in the
army you can pick up a manual
and it will show you how to conduct a
raid you can pick up a manual can show
you how to conduct a reconnaissance it
can show you how to conduct an immediate
action drill
in the city in the urban environment in
the rural environment
you can pick the manual to find all
those things and in the seal teams we
didn't have that it was all
passed down word of mouth over years and
so you couldn't just pick up a manual
and say oh refer to the manual on this
that's a disadvantage because it's nice
to have somewhere to start from
but it's an advantage because our minds
are very flexible
and very good at problem solving and
that turns out to be
advantageous when you get tasked with a
mission that there is no manual for
and that's what we're able to do with
working out of vehicles and we ended up
being
extremely proficient in vehicle
operations
very shortly after we started doing them
for the first time
pretty that's one of the best things
about the seal teams
open minds and flexibility you know and
i
from my perspective it's more than that
that the guys that go into seal team
and it's it's got its good points and
it's bad points just like you said
commander
but they're a different breed of people
and i i really believe
that that they can make things happen i
mean guys
just come out of the blue and say yeah
we're going to do this and we have this
process
and it's a legitimate process and it
works
i mean what a gift from god you know
it's a gift from a god
the way a lot of sealed teams socially
they're weird
but you put them in the battle situation
am i not right
you're right socially they're as weird
as a day islam
oh he's coming i'll give an example of
that
we had a medal of honor winner well
before he was medal of honor
the team bar was the trade winds and ago
the trade winds at 4 30
getting off work and he see you'd walk
in the door and he had to screen in
front of the door
you'd walk in the door see this one guy
sitting at the bar
you would immediately go down around the
screen go out
because you knew there was going to be a
fight in like 15 minutes right
and the guy turned out to be a medal of
honor winner but i mean
that's the beauty of the teams that we
allow people like that to go in
and prosper and contribute to the
to the effort i mean that's the beauty
yeah what a wonderful thing
a gift from god yeah
so you when you got back home from that
deployment
what came next well can i just go a
little yeah i want to talk about
that forever if you would oh yeah that's
right the charity you ran in baghdad
i want to talk about that so uh i always
like to support
uh the chaplains because they did a lot
of good things for a lot of people
right and so i would go talk to the
chaplain he happened to be a catholic
chaplain
and i said uh father what what can we
what can we do for you how can we help
you he said man we got this
we got this orphanage just christian
orphanage run by german nuns they had
three german nuns
in baghdad and they're constantly being
harangued
by the locals especially since the war
started
and we could use a little help on that i
said what do you need he says well they
really need money
and i said really they need money and so
i went to i went to the morning mayor's
meeting we had a more
mid morning mayor's meeting at 10
o'clock
and that was every unit on biop sent a
representative and we would all help
each other
the most help they ever gave me is when
the grom needed gasoline because
everything else didn't need gasoline
i got gasoline for the grom i was able
to trade
to the grom and then i needed a pair of
quadruple e size 9
boots now who in god's name takes a
brand new pair
of triple or quadruple e size
9 boots some guy defoliated his boot
right
and i was able to do that to get that
but i was really happy about that but
that cost me some big
big things to do that so
um i i say okay i go to the morning
the mayor's morning meeting and i said
okay after the meeting
anybody can talk right after the mayor i
said okay there's 44 seals here
in biop and we want to challenge the
army
in a contest everybody's looking at me
posey sit down you dumb ass
okay you're stupid i said yeah we're
gonna we're gonna kick your ass
okay i said we're raising money for this
catholic charity uh downtown buy-up
and we will us 44 guys i think there was
12 000 guys at the base there
is going to outraise the united states
army a few marine guys
okay we're gonna we're gonna out raise
you because these people need money
and they said you dumb ass and i said
we're gonna call it and i don't i'm
gonna just say the guy's first name
john t i want to say his last name and i
had this jar
in my hand this big cookie jar like this
clear cookie jar
and i had his picture on the front of it
with this big lettering
the john t blank
orphans fund and so
i and i had a hole in it where they
could stick money right
so people after the meeting says you
know my father was in the navy
don't let anybody see me put money in
this jar but
i'm going to put money in this jar and
we're going to get more money for you
and i said fine
so i go to back and i tell our guys i
said we're in this we're doing this
charity thing
and we named it after our army ranger
john t and he comes up and he says posey
are you out of your mind
he says i i don't i don't help orphans i
make orphans
i said you just you just relax big boy
i'm going to take care of this right
so we did this for i think 45 days and i
would taunt them
every morning mayor's morning meeting i
oh seal team now has 10
000 iraqi dinar uh
what are you guys doing you know what
where's the army at
uh in the army rep well we got 300 and
so
i would taunt them every morning and the
people just i mean
they would i would drive my humvee down
buy off
and they'd wave at me and come and give
me a handful of money
american dollars but mainly uh iraqi
dinar
and so finally we ended up with six
boxes
of money six medium or
small boxes of money and
then we went to the the nunnery and
delivered this money
so we were afraid that by doing that
that we would draw the attention of the
iraqis that they would come
and raid these poor nuns and kill them
and do whatever for this money because
it was
i mean i don't know how much money we
had but we had a ton of money
and so they the commander their
seal team says okay here's what we're
going to do we're going to do a raid on
this nunnery
and we're going to be very ugly to them
when we go in and we go out
so that we can protect them you know
we're going to act like we're going to
hook them and the kids up and so we did
that
and so i go knock on the door
and i talked to this kid and i said i
want to deliver something to the nuns
and so he let me in and i go talk to
them i said
sister we have this she barely spoke
english
we have money for you uh where would you
like it
and she says oh you can just put her on
this little card table they had right
there
so i mentioned to my guys in the humvee
to come in and we were
doing t.o.t because we were really
worried about
spending too much time there that it was
a social call and not you know some kind
of a bad call
and so my guys come in and they're
banging on the door with their gun butts
and
just being ugly when they go we're gonna
get you what you did
you know they were really good and these
break these six
boxes of money and i said at that time
it was very difficult
to find cardboard boxes at buy up it was
impossible
and i wanted my boxes back i said where
do you want she says right there
so we start dumping these boxes of money
up and it was a stack about two feet
tall
and it's going all over the floor she
looks at me and said
who are you guys i said well i don't
know we're
the army right
so i said we have we're doing this she
said why don't you sit down and have
lunch with us we're going to have lunch
and we have pepsicola and i said sister
we're going to be out of here in 30
seconds
we just have to make this look ugly
because we don't want them to come
and give you a bad time and and steal
this money from you she says we
understand
so we're banging our way out you know
they're pointing the guns at the nunnery
in this whole thing
and so we just x-filled and so
uh that i heard later on that that was
really good for them because they were
really having a hard time financially
you know feeding i think they had 60
kids there
so it was really good and it was really
good because the army really supported
us
that's awesome that's where the bulk of
the money came from obviously
and it was really wonderful that they
did that so more power to them huh
and it's also wonderful that the press
didn't pick up any pictures of a young
seal holding his weapon aimed at some
nun
i'm surprised that didn't happen we
don't do too great with the pressure
no i made her stay in the house and the
kid walked me out got it because
we were trying to be very cognizant of
that you know but we didn't want to
leave a trail
that they would have problems oh for
sure if it looked like they were helping
coalition forces that's a death sentence
right
right so good tactic that worked out
so so eventually you though you end up
in this you did 30 combat operations you
saved a bunch of orphans
i mean this is just bill posey on the
rampage you've
supplied the whole seal teams with
everything they needed repaired a
thousand humvees
but but you got to a point where you
were too banged up and
and you no my funding ran out so i was
on reserve funding on non-active duty
my funding i was on active duty but the
funding from the reserves was paying me
and so then they told me to come back
out
and so oh i thought you got injured you
came home because you were hurt
no but i was hurt but it didn't it
didn't bother me i mean
at the bottom i don't know for whatever
reason the bottoms of my feet were
killing me but that you know what can
you do
you know you got to do what you got to
do
so you know that was really uh a good
thing
and then they sent me
this is really funny well maybe it's not
funny that
i come back and i this admiral calls me
and he says posey no it wasn't it was an
army
i mean a navy captain your fundings ran
out you have to go home
and i said what do you mean i have to go
home i'm i'm hurt i got to get fixed you
got to fix me
he says no no i'm giving you a direct
order
you have to you have to disengage
yourself
and so is this was this when you got
back to the state yes
just got back to you you got back to say
you're dinged up now you're banged up
and you're like hey
i need to get some medical treatment
before i
so i look like chester right i'm going
give him one of these right
and i said you guys got to fix me
and so he says no i'm giving you direct
order you have to report into the
x-fill tomorrow and get out i said
okay so i go of course a warrant officer
i mean not that we're brilliant but we
know how the navy works
we know how the whole thing works and
there's
chapter and verse on any given situation
so i go to the instruction you know one
zero zero
three three one and i look at it and i
pull pulled instruction out
and i talked to the
captain the next day and i said captain
do you know about
instruction one zero zero three one and
he says
no i don't but i don't care what it is
you will report tonight this afternoon
at 12. i said no i won't
i'm not being disrespectful sir i talked
to my command
they stand behind me and that you guys
have to fix me
and you can't send me home. and he says
well we'll see about that
so i immediately i left there and i went
to talk to my congressman
who i knew because i was doing things
and i said you know i'm not being
disrespectful i love the navy
i'm not disrespectful i'm not that kind
of guy i'm not a
you know seaboard lawyer but you have to
fix me
and i was at the clinic every day and i
knew all these kids that they were
mustering out
i mean an e3 marine corps guy
mustering out there sending him home and
he can't even walk
i mean he can't do anything right and
they sent i think
60 of those people home and so
i go to my congressman i said sir you've
got to help me
i mean this is not right what they're
doing to all these kids i can get along
i can make it happen right because i can
go to the va or whatever
but it's not right what you're doing to
these kids so he calls the admiral and
they straightened it out so i'm in six
months of rehab
and i went to the clinic there that we
have the seal team
and they really helped me so i was
really happy about what was going on
there and
you know then my time was up and i went
home
so it was good
what'd you do when we went home
i started flipping houses again so i'm
good at carpentry and that kind of stuff
and flipping houses
and then i moved to texas and
i worked for the i was working in oil
field for a while
as a service component of the oil field
and then i got the job uh teaching
school
how did you end up in the job teaching
school what made you decide to do that
uh because i couldn't do the oil field
job my back
i didn't know my back was broken right i
didn't know i was just having all these
back problems and
feet problems and i thought it was just
old age of course we all get old right i
mean
you guys are even feeling it at 25
yeah 26 26 okay
but you know and so i had to quit that
oil field job
and then and i found this
teaching job through this part of our
church has this high school
and so the guy calls me in and he says
you know you've never taught before and
you only have a
college degree but you don't have a
teacher credential you know but uh
you know maybe we can help you so they
hired me i was lucky enough to they
hired me
and so that was really for the last
eight years been a really
good gig for me because my objective
there is to have
those kids not make the same mistakes
that i've made
i've made a lot of mistakes in my life
you know and i
i did a lot of stupid things so
what subject do you teach uh history
government economics and art
and bible but it's a wide range yeah but
it's a it's a
you know it's a small school so you do
everything
you know we only have like 175 kids
enrolled in high school
are you singing are you getting feedback
from kids that graduated four years ago
six years ago eight years ago that you
had an impact on
um yeah um yeah
i think so i mean they tell me you know
we really loved your class whatever
because i tell you know the problem at
least my perception
i'm probably speaking out of turn but
the problem is
they treat the kids like kids you know
how many in
world war ii even in vietnam you had
these guys that were 16 and 17 years old
you know going to the war i mean in
world war ii
full jihad going under the war right
going to the war
you know against the german superpower
and we say these kids are kids when
they're 18 years old
they're not kids they're adults don't
baby him
so i try not to baby now i just give it
to him straight you know this is
this is what's really happening you know
think you know
my objective read write be able to
present yourself
uh think and then act
i mean if you can think you're dangerous
right
you're dangerous you're full-on
dangerous
because i i don't think a lot of the
schools now want you to think
it's not a good thing
and then what you also apparently now
you're you have your own radio show
i do so what's that all about how can we
listen to that oh yeah i don't think you
want to uh
commander uh i just have this little
we do we talk politics every morning
from 6 30 to 7 on 95.9
tajano radio victoria texas
and we talk about things that are going
on and
especially things that are going on in
the republican party and
uh how we can you know fight back from
what we think
has not been well for us in the past
here
especially the past couple of years and
how old are you right now
i'm gonna be 75 in six months is there
any
part of your brain that thinks maybe
you're gonna you know retire and sit on
the
front porch and drink coffee in the
morning and watch the grass grow
you know the problem is i really hate
old people i hate old people
and i don't want to be associated i
don't want to talk to them i don't want
to do anything with old people
so i really find it you know when you're
a kid
and you have every possibility in the
world out there
every possibility that you can do
anything you want
right you can do whatever you want what
a wonderful time in life right
instead of some 70 oh my back my side
i mean they all want to talk about their
operations i don't give a rat's ass
about their operations
right i don't care so
i like dealing with interfacing with the
kids
and you know trying to give it you know
i don't think it's a
not in doctrine well maybe it is
indoctrination but i'm really big on the
constitution the declaration of
independence
of the things that your grandfather my
father
your great grandfather did for america i
mean let's honor those people
i mean especially like memorial day
today let's honor those
folks and thank them for all the
wonderful things and allowing us to have
the wonderful things that we have in
this nation you know
so that's my objective you know teaching
school
i am slowing down covet uh
was really uh mentally hard on me
and so i hope i don't lose my mind here
in the next three years because i hope
to teach for the next three years
well i'll tell you what that's a
freaking about as good of a closing as
we could ever hope for here echo you got
anything
usually if you haven't listened well
you've listened to the podcast so echo
you know speaking you were talking about
some weird
social things sometimes echo throws out
some weird social questions right now we
don't know what's coming
actually more more for clarity than
anything back to apollo 12.
what was your job there well like what
was your i was the first man out the
door so i would hook the
slow down parachute to the side and then
we would put the capsule
the collar around the capsule then our
decontamination because we thought there
was moon bugs
the decontamination rafts would be
inflated put it on the side
we'd hope the decontamination man would
open the door
and uh put the astronauts in the
rafts and then they'd go up in the in
the helicopter
just to go a little bit further i think
echo i got to take it back one step
so you remember you've seen the the the
capsule splashing down into the ocean
the capital from the
fro from the from the rocket yeah like
it goes to the moon whatever it goes up
into space
and then to get back it just splashes
down in the middle of the ocean
so somebody's got to go recover that
capsule and get those astronauts out
yeah
that someone udt that's someone
bill posey coming in hot first guy out
the door of the
of the helicopter of the helicopter so
the helicopter and actually if you go to
the
uss midway yes they have one of those
helicopters the
helicopter that's the 66. wait that's
your helicopter
yes sir the 12 yes sir and they've got a
little freddy the frog
on there ready to get some compliments
of pete carolyn
he he painted that up so
there you go yeah yeah that makes sense
now yeah i started to gather
that but oh yeah i want to make sure
that that was the see people who lived
through apollo
just think everybody knows about it i
apologize for not being clear now no no
all good
seemed pretty exciting though a billion
people watching it
oh yeah and there he is and out the door
first
bill posey from linwood california in
full color for mom
who was highly selected highly selected
through a rigorous program to get there
making a fool of myself because i can't
find a d
rig well
sir awesome i i i really can't thank you
enough
for for coming on and obviously for your
service to the country to the navy
to the teams you know it was it was you
guys that
that formed our for
you formed who we are in the seal teams
in the in the udts
coming up through vietnam and then you
kept that thread going and you brought
it all the way
to iraq to camp jenny posey for us
thanks for everything thanks for thanks
for helping our legacy exists
no no let's not let let's put
credit where credit's due um i worked at
group one
that oversees all the west coast seal
teams and i would deal with seal team
three all the time
and i would work with uh uh you
lieutenant commander and it was
really great working with three i really
enjoyed working with three
because we could really get things done
and thanks for the leadership and
everything that you did over there
you were an inspiration to us all and
even though you've written these books
and i don't know if you remember this or
not you wrote something
just before i got out and it was really
inspiring what you wrote
and i wrote you back and i said man this
is a great piece you ought to be an
author
so you know give credit where credit's
due guys like you that grind it
right down to this fine dust and that
you can make things happen thank you for
your service
yeah well we wouldn't have been able to
do anything without the the legacy that
you guys put forth for us
so teamwork and the teams amen until the
end
airborne thank you sir hi
and with that warrant officer bill posey
has
left the building
some good stuff
man about how to be a good frogman and
how to be a
good human
a guy that's been in the game and stayed
in the game right stayed in the game 56
years old
rolling out on ops getting after it it's
it's funny to hear
like everyone else or everyone's take on
things you know you
have various guests and their different
takes on things
and like his take on it was kind of like
for like a better way of putting it like
it was just just kind of easy
like it was just one big ride that he
was on kind of thing
he was like oh can you imagine showing
up to buds which used to be called udd
udt trout replacement training
replacement
can you imagine you show up and you
think you you'd go do i need a book bag
because you think you're going to look
to a freaking educational native school
and you're actually entering what's
allegedly the toughest military training
you're like whatever yeah what like i
surfed and i played water polo bring it
what do you got
what are we doing you want me to get wet
be cold cool watch this i'm gonna sleep
for 15 minutes in the front of the boat
i'll be good when i'm done right roger
that hey there
what are we going to knob cool are we
doing beach recons
roger that oh we're going on patrols
getting in a swift boat getting shot up
hiding behind a piece of freaking
body armor cool i'm down what apollo
okay cool what i gotta do hook the
[ __ ] in like
he's just getting it the whole time yeah
i think well there's a lot of my
favorite points of that
but when i asked him about retiring he's
like
i don't like old people what a freaking
epic cancer
he's 75 years old whatever he's like
what
yes no i got stuff i'm gonna do i'm out
here making stuff happen
yeah i started a radio program by the
way it's kind of true when he talks
about um
like old people talk about their
operations yeah he's not talking about
his operations
he's talking about going iraq yeah
he said one one little thing that he
said that stood out to me when he was
like
oh yeah they throw you over the over the
deck or whatever in the
water and to see if you're
claustrophobic yeah the casual way that
he said that
i was like oh they'd go because they
just want to see if they cost
that he's talking about i'm assuming
it's the old school
with the biggest thing like 20 000
leagues under the sea scenario
you know what i'm saying a
claustrophobic uh in the bottom of the
bay yeah that seems like a way bigger
deal than his tone was when he said it
seems like not a lot of stuff was a big
deal
he was just jumping out of helicopters
hooking in apollo 12
going on patrol with with 30 oh by the
way dropping danger close napalm
that luckily happened to be there as you
were about to get over ron
whatever yeah watching rolling up to
baghdad
landing jumping out of a freaking c130
that's going down a highway what are you
talking about
no factor he was like oh yeah then this
happened whatever just part of the ride
he was on
really you know man freaking awesome
thank you camp jenny posey
i can't i don't know if i can relay that
enough
what that what that name
had to be to
er it was this moment in time right that
can never be recaptured camp jenny posey
that's crazy like everyone that was at
camp jenny posey oh yeah
oh you were at posey like it's a little
thing yeah you know bro i mean i'm not
trying to get crazy we weren't
freaking you know wasn't the battle the
bulge but for the
seals at that moment in time is pretty
freaking awesome
pretty freaking awesome cam jenny posey
welcome home welcome home
is what it said on that sign welcome
home
and that was jenny posey yeah by the way
for those of you that are just listening
jenny posey was in the room
you know because she had did end up
graduating from army or rotc
and she was here laughing because i
could see her she was laughing at
stories and
and and also you know she told me
afterwards she's never heard all these
stories huh
you know she's never heard all these
stories about nom
about getting thrown over the side into
the
into the damn bay to walk around for
half an hour
by the way that's an ignorant test
that's like the witch test
that's like the witch test we'll throw
you in the water and if you
drown then that means you're not a witch
but if you survive means you're a witch
and we're going to kill you check this
out
we want to see if you're claustrophobic
or if you like the water so we're going
to throw you in the water
what happens if you're not comfortable
what are we doing then
yeah like you you just freaking get all
wrapped up in your
in your in your lines to the surface and
next thing you know you got that lead
boots up and we got
problems yeah it seemed problematic
yeah that's not like the safest test we
got for
our do they still do that no no there'll
be
dead people all over the bay can't be
throwing people in the water
that's that's only the bill posey
freaking test that's brutal
all right well so speaking of staying in
the game
long term which is what we're looking to
do yes how can we stay in the game
longer build posey style okay we want to
keep ourselves capable
capable in every way physical
mental emotional spiritual
social when do we start throwing social
into this part of life
okay from keep that one fro you need
like you need
robust relationships you do maybe not
robust
we'll just say healthy relationships how
about that either way
we're gonna talk about the physical and
mental so you you want to be exercising
we want to be exercising we want to be
doing jiu jitsu
we want to be eating well here's the
thing with eating well
it's really hard to get all
the nutrients that you need okay it's
hard for all
yeah agreed yeah even if you have a
perfect diet
in real life we which no one does
there's no such thing well maybe there's
some freaking uh
like hollywood whatever that's up there
that has like the personal chef and has
the person coming in with the
you know plucking the kale from
flocking the kale from you know northern
bulgaria where it's grown without
any uh interference from man
right and then steamed for like
you know like 38.1 yeah
at 17 degrees celsius
exactly so that person might have a
perfect diet no
but and even then but even unless they
don't have a job oh that's what i'm
saying those people up in hollywood they
don't have a job yeah they just sit
there
yeah and don't do anything no offense to
my people in hollywood but come on let's
get real
what about though you know it's really
hard being on the set all day
shut up bill posey was getting thrown
over a boat with a freaking hard hat
helmet on
to wander around in the muck that's been
there for 150 years
that was hard yeah that was yes being on
set
no you get zero credit yeah it's hard to
compare the do you get zero credit
did bill posey get a fresh bulgarian
kale salad when he got out of the water
well he did a negative so even if you
eat where are we going
even if we do have a fresh bulgarian
kale salad and everything else perfect
balanced
meals in whatever way you're balancing
them because we're all different in a
lot of ways
very hard to get these the the all the
nutrients that
we need and want okay good news
chocolate supplements good news
supplementation for
us that was the longest with the perfect
diet a perfect diet or a not so perfect
diet supplementation is going to get you
way ahead of the game keep you in the
game that's what it's going to do so
what do we got and what do we have them
for we got them for your joints for your
mind
for your body and for your muscles
directly
joint warfare joint work grill oil super
krill oil
these are for your joints like okay and
this is going to be a big deal
because if your joints fail you you can
be strong
you can be strong you can be capable you
can run every day your joints start
failing you start bothering you or
whatever what good is it having a 454
big blocker you got a flat tire over
here exactly right rear
you know what i'm saying exactly you're
not going anywhere oh yeah or you can
rev your engine a little bit just like
you can stand there and flex in the
mirror but you're not going to be able
to take anybody in a jiu jitsu match
yeah that's for sure you got a bad wheel
it's true absolutely so we need to have
the
the joints up to speed let's see and
trust me i know i've
i've experienced both well what what a
true testament is
joint warfare there's subscribe people
that subscribe
subscribe to join warfare all the time
and the feedback is awesome because
people realize
they go oh maybe i don't need it anymore
then they go a week and a half
and they're they're like crackheads
running back so yeah subscribe hit
they want to have it and they don't want
to miss it all kinds of
good stuff in that also vitamin d3
yep okay so look maybe some of us work
outside and we get
you know sun and then even then i think
you still might be lacking
in vitamin d3 why roll the dice don't
why roll the dice
don't roll the dice on your vitamin d
nope get some
easy and the teeny tiny ones you know
some people they don't like swallowing
those
big remember the old school uh what is
it freaking
amino acids or whatever remember that
those big ass
horsemen yeah yeah yeah it's not like
that no teeny tiny easy money
you're good to go yeah exactly you're
good to go also
for immunity along with the vitamin d3
is cold war in these times
we're not sometimes our immune system
sometimes it needs a little attention
extra attention
i'd say that's a good call it's true we
just got back from a trip
and that's sometimes that's the time
where your immune system gonna need a
little
little spot sometimes so yeah you got
the you got the cold war
from choco fuel also uh
protein in the form of dessert it's
called milk yes is there a new flavor
okay it's so good it's so ridiculous
we we just got to the mo we just got
done with the muster and i i don't know
why i asked jamie this
i got paranoid but i was like i was
about to fly out and she was out there
before getting everything set up and i
texted her i was like hey do we have
milk out there
and she's like are you serious of course
she's like of course we have more we
have plenty more
essential dude i was out there just just
taking because they bought my
so beautiful i showed up they got a
refrigerator in my room
there's milk in the refrigerator
hollywood guy over here
yeah so i get there and there's milk and
then there's milk
and i was just well this is what i was
doing i was taking like
opening up the milk bottle and just
drinking a little bit of milk and
pouring milk in there and shaking it
was so freaking good to go it's such a
game changer
you're on the road and you're you're
just eating clean
so legit get yourself some milk yeah and
by the way right now i've been on peanut
butter
the chocolate peanut butter cup for like
probably a month right now
and i got everything i started i'm
looking at my cupboard and i'm like
thinking could it be mint
could it be mint could it be strawberry
maybe a little vanilla griddle and i
just keep for the past month i've been
grabbing that
grabbing that chocolate peanut butter
it's a reese's peanut butter
milkshake it's that freaking good
yep same boat same but oh so you're
there yeah all right
so one of the one of our people
at the muster was thanking me for
whatever reason
for the uh milk the raw milk or the one
the non-flavored one
yeah he's thanking me for that i told
him hey man you're welcome there's no
problem for me
to get that out no you know so
brian pete oh you guys cool cool but you
know
you're welcome so that's a good that's
an interesting one though
so if like yeah if you don't prefer like
a flavor
necessarily i mean it's kind of hard to
imagine but
hey man everybody's different man got
that option is there a banana thing
flavor coming up banana banana is coming
a banana milk i've obviously have you
had it have you had the new no no
no what's the name is there on the
inside
freaking good name not confirmed yet but
we're getting there
and it should be out it's good man it's
like a banana cream scenario yeah
and that's so freaking good yeah it's
kind of ridiculous
again you feel like you you feel like
you're having a dessert
straight up like that lately with that
peanut now yesterday i did actually
yesterday had a mint yesterday i had
mint which was good to go
so it's kind of like it's essentially a
cheat code it's one of those cheat codes
all right
we need to move on i started to feel
like we're in this weird tangent world
where
like you and i are getting super hyped
you know why because you're imagining
drinking right now and i understand but
so yeah so get it for yourself how about
that
get it at jacofuel.com and get all this
stuff
you can get you can get um we have a
drink too by the way a beverage
that's true when i was in florida we at
the muster we we
supplied we'll say our people with the
discipline go
and man so good to go
so good to go and then went to wawa down
there in florida
which is pretty freaking cool going in a
wawa
walk to the fridge there you go yeah you
can just there you go
looks like in wawa what's up with that
cool here's the thing right now there's
people like oh we're making a healthy
energy drink
[ __ ] you're actually lying there's
only one person that's making a
a healthy energy drink right now us we
are yeah i guess there's only one
team that's making a healthy energy
drink right now
there's only one team that said you know
what we're not gonna put a bunch of
freaking chemicals in here to preserve
this that are going to go in your body
and preserve your body in some weird way
that's what you do when you die you go
to a mortician and they
preserve your body yeah they put those
chemicals into the drink and say oh it's
cool it's good drink it
no we didn't do that we pasteurize it we
pasteurize this we have to add any of
those chemicals
look at you'll notice i almost i almost
got sucked in
some guy commented on some social media
thing
he was like oh this uh you know just a
standard
he's trying to there he me trying to
pitch you know some uh you know some
supplement it's the same as everything
else it's actually
literally not the same as everything
else all you have to do is look at the
ingredients and you realize oh it's
actually
not it's not having close to everything
else not even close it's a totally
different ball game
so if you're thinking that you're wrong
you kind of
i mean you know i try to give people the
benefit of the doubt
and you can kind of understand because
when you think about it try to exclude
you
exclude yourself in what what this whole
you know
discipline go thing exclude that so i'm
not a part of it pretend it doesn't
exist
how about that the drink doesn't exist
yeah yeah okay and let's say even you
don't exist
um okay he has a point
that guy saying oh he's just like
everything you know it's like everyone
everything else or whatever you know
like oh yeah just some peddling some
you know whatever he has no idea he's
the thing is he's right
except now he's not right because you're
not but everyone else kind of does that
you seem saying
so if i didn't exist as a human yes this
guy would be correct would be correct
yes
so you kind of like if he don't know he
just decayed you know what decayed means
no didn't know oh chad so if you didn't
you know how you don't you know you did
you got you get dk'd a lot actually
people don't know me
they just don't know oh yeah and they're
just like oh look at that yeah they just
assume
yeah yeah they just assume like everyone
else like remember that time about the
warrior kid book
he was like on twitter back in the day
yeah
chimed in yeah like so i forget who
posted it but someone posted something
saying oh yeah like um
you know uh where they were kid from
wimpy to warrior the navy
whatever and some professor or something
mm-hmm
was like oh just another guy peddling
toxic masculinity or something like this
i'm paraphrasing some comments and he
goes uh um
sorry i'll pass right like didn't read
it look at you pulling the quote yeah
yeah you know didn't look into the whole
thing and everyone just piled up on him
saying hey
essentially brad you're decaying this
guy it's not that
it's like whatever my daughters read it
like that kind and he was like oh
he was backpedaling whatever but totally
decayed you mm-hmm so
you know it's just another dk situation
weird though that someone would make
that move
like like let's face it what's a good
lesson to learn when you're a kid that
almost everybody learns don't judge a
book by its cover
almost everybody does learns that lesson
and here's a guy that double violated
that number one
looking at me and judging the book by
its cover and then number two
straight up judging the book by its
cover straight up literally doing that
and this guy is a professor who's you
know
uh a liberal guy because i was you know
who is this guy and he's some
super liberal guy look i get all kinds
of liberal people that read the books
no factor they're like oh yeah this
guy's an open mind cool just
decayed me yeah twice
but even worse broke the act broke the
broke the
metaphorical rule and broke the straight
up real literal rule
broke it right there for he should have
got two l's in this column right
loser loser double up yeah yeah fully
and yeah being liberal or not liberal
that wasn't in this case the violation
it was a man who cares ignorance yeah
that was a violation if he was a super
liberal guy that read the book and was
like hey
i think that the way you portray xyz i'd
be like okay cool yeah that's good good
feedback
i need to pay attention to that it's
true well
so yeah so hey look so for future
reference
you will get dk'd in the future as well
yeah and this energy drink
situation he just decayed yourself it's
all good bro
the ingredients are filtered carbonated
water
natural flavor citric acid monk fruit
extract
that's that's the ingredients now look
are there there are other ingredients
that are like the supplement part
vitamin b12
vitamin b6 like
caffeine alpha gpc like those are real
ingredients that are in there but
they're
supplemental they're good for you yeah
the bat where's the bad for you
ingredients on here
there are not there you go that's the
way they should do like that should be
the new labeling system right
what there should be two columns good
for you bad for you
that would be right reality it's too
much reality but that's the way it
should be
because people don't know it's true
people don't know that that that
all those chemicals that are getting put
in there they should be in the bad for
you column
yeah by the way yeah kind of like
cigarettes yeah they'll cigarettes they
say hey you can get cancer from
yeah they should just have one column
that says this
left side makes you strong right side
makes you weak exactly right
kills you poisoned you
yeah all right so yeah all right
uh so wah-wah you can get the drinks at
wawa you can get all the stuff at
vitamin shop
you can get all the stuff at
jockofuel.com
and also kind of important
if you subscribe if you subscribe to
whatever it is you want
the shipping is free because we don't
want you have to pay for shipping
so if you subscribe shipping is free
because we know that there's other
organizations out there that offer free
shipping
we want to make sure you have the option
if you don't want to go through those
big organizations but you still want to
get free shipping we got you covered
we got you covered no factor it's a big
deal man free shipping seems small
it's a big deal and you don't forget to
take your stuff to or you don't run out
you don't run the risk of running out
that's a big deal too
by the way take it from me i've been
there also you can get it at or
originusa.com and i'll say originusa.com
you can get american-made stuff
jiu-jitsu for sure jeans
american-made denim boots
i have your boots by the way still then
all my boots are your birds they're mine
no
power boots but here's the thing i have
some oh the boots that you brought home
so those are my boots yes
yeah apparently you didn't bring them
today well my son was trying to wear him
and i was like okay cool he wanted to
walk a mile in your shoes literally
yeah american-made shoes um also yeah
denim
boots uh belts oh wait wait are they
doing belts in other
wallets yes belts wallets boots homemade
in america
all made in america 100 yeah 100 without
compromise
you know how hard it is when you say
without compromise on the end of
something
especially something like making stuff
in america that's a big bold statement
because there's like a rivet for a pair
of jeans yeah and everybody's like cool
yeah we get rivets from china oh good to
go
yeah yeah cool that's negligible no big
deal
no big deal we're not worried about
those particular slave labor elements
that are working in a sweatshop we're
not worried about them because it's
rivets and we need them
yeah that's the easy thing to do look we
got most of the genes made in america
we look most of our stuff is made by
americans that are actually
actually enjoying their job we got most
of our parts not made by slave labor
that's kind of cool right yeah
no it's actually not cool that's
actually a good point like how you're
like
the rivets they seem small it's small so
it's it kind of until you're a 12 year
old kid
getting freaking in the big
18 hours a day yeah that's cool yeah go
ahead
get yourself those other get yourself
those other
jeans savages man
so yes if if hey look if this kind of
stuff interests you
you want this kind of stuff
originusa.com
also jacqueline's store it's called
jocko store
so go to jackostore.com this is where
you can get your display equals freedom
shirts
hats hoodies this is also this is higher
quality stuff it's not
ballpark giveaway free
quality stuff it's high quality stuff
trust me i know that too also we have a
subscription situation new called the
shirt locker
so you get a new shirt every month
free shipping on that one as well the
designs are more
creative more fun you got to trust me on
that one
because like if you're if you're like
hey prove it and then like you look at
it you're like oh you're right
it's too late eddie you don't get that
shirt anymore i will say at the muster
when i saw our people with some shirt
locker shirts on
i felt i felt a little extra like
connection i felt the same way
exactly right kind of a little extra
connection we know they're
like look we get we get there in the
game but then when you see that you're
like oh they're
in the game in the game in the game and
looking to do full support
yep so yes check it out
jacquelinestore.com if you like
something
get something subscribe to the podcast
don't forget about other podcasts that
we have jocko unraveling with daryl
cooper daryl cooper just dropped the new
martyr made podcast yeah i noticed that
okay so you can you can go check that
out
i think we he and i had prepped to do
a podcast and then we ended up not doing
that particular one
for the unraveling and then i think he
just
kind of took some of that and went went
deep on it which as you know
dc can go deep on some stuff so so check
out jocko unraveling
check out martyrmaid check out the
grounded podcast which
dean list we've got to do some recording
with him and the warrior kid podcast
we also have the the jocko
underground.com
so look we don't know what's gonna
happen with any of these platforms
is the bottom line we we could get
cut off for whatever reason we could get
ads imposed on us from other things that
we don't
necessarily want to be doing
advertisements for
there's all kinds of things that can
happen we realize this we need to have a
contingency plan
we we built the structure
for a our own platform if we need to do
it
so if people if all of a sudden things
get crazy
we will be standing by we'll be on the
jockowunderground.com
if you want to help us out with that so
that we never have to
rely on anyone else and we don't have to
have
we have to do ad reads in the middle of
a freaking podcast
right hey warren officer posey you're
telling us about what was like in
vietnam hold on a second i'm going to
talk about a new whatever
right after these messages yeah right
after these messages you can tell us
what it was like
no we're not doing that so if you want
to help out eight dollars and eighteen
cents a month if you can't afford it
that doesn't mean we don't want you in
the game we want you in the game you can
go to
you can email assistants at
jockowinderground.com and so we're
releasing
one podcast a week where we kind of do a
little
topics that are we'll say related to but
not quite
the normal topic for jocko pondcast it's
more of like an expansion
more in depth so you can check out that
and we also have a youtube channel
that you can subscribe to if you want to
see uh some of the stuff
a lot of these things i'm the assistant
director on sure
most of the good ones i'm the assistant
director on they're all good
no maybe some people they're not all
good okay
yeah all right uh subscribe to that
youtube channel also origin usa has a
youtube channel you can check that out
as well yep
also psychological warfare if you don't
know what that is
it's not on the youtube channel but it
is an
album a jocko album with tracks
and each track helps you get through an
individual moment of
weakness that you might have and we all
have them from time to time
bro i had one the other day not
yesterday day before
wait was it yesterday yeah day before
yesterday
yep but you know how like
yeah you're the one who did this where
if you have a moment of weakness and you
get past it you got to punish yourself
for having the moment or weakness so you
got to add on what do you have like a
set
or a 10 percent 15 percent burpees could
be starve yourself for 14 hours i don't
know
but somebody got to pay for that hey man
those chocolate chippy chocolate chip
cookies were good to go
and i'm fasting tomorrow what you got to
pay for that and yeah so
man that happened to me what was the
moment
i wanted to skip the workout i actually
didn't want to skip it i was into it i
warmed up you know the kind where it's
like hey if i just start warming up i'm
going to be in the workout yeah it was
harder than that
the moment of weakness was bigger and
more robust than that i warmed up
i did like two good sets and i was like
kind of like hey i did those two solid
sets right there
so if i don't do the second half of this
workout
we kind of go i can just finish these
set and be done you know
so i was like oh man so i got through it
i said ah no i didn't i did the whole
workout
and then as a punishment i had to do a
metcon there you go and i doubled up on
the met content bang
yeah check right on you can get that
from
anywhere you get mp3s also if you want
to hang something up in your wall
you can go to flipsidecampus.com dakota
meyer my brother is making all kinds of
cool stuff to hang on your wall
also i got a bunch of books we have
final spin coming
final spin coming i wrote
i wrote a book could be novel could be
could be some other format of reading of
writing
could be poetry with a mixture of prose
with a mixture of transcripts of human
beings talking
that basically i made my own form up am
i allowed to do that
at this point but i guess i did um
story it's available now for pre-order
if you want to get that first
when does it come out november 16th is
when it comes out
here's the thing you know what the
publisher is saying
the publisher's like well you know
you're kind of a guy that writes about
leaner camps and we don't know
right big question you know yeah big
question mark we're not sure if you're
people that listen to you your podcast
will actually want to read some kind of
a weird
novel from you it's like okay cool it's
true so they're not going to print
enough
and then people are going to order it
when you know in on on november
14th they'll be like oh cool i want to
get a copy they're gonna end up with a
second a dish
and there's no this is not a redeemable
situation
you know you make some decisions in life
you can never go back from like you get
a tattoo
on your forehead seemed like a good idea
right
but you can't go back from that yeah
right you can't go back from that
it's there now you could go get it
removed then you got a scar on your
forehead either way
we're not thinking that that's the the
move that we can
go back from yes hey you go out drinking
and you decide you're gonna go for a
drive afterwards you get a dui there's
no
you don't go like hey hey officer
you know what let's hit rewind right you
can't do that
you show up i'm you know you come to the
muster you come to jonco live you roll
up
you got that you got you got that copy
of final spin and you're like i'd really
like to get this signed i open it up i'm
going to sign it i'm going to sign it
like cool man i appreciate it but then i
see the second dish down there and i'm
sort of knowing
i'm sort of seeing where you're at you
know i'm sort of seeing where we're at
you know i'm sort of seeing where we're
at i know that
at the moment of truth you were kind of
like well
and now you can't you can't walk back
that decision again you could work
through it right you're still going to
go out you can wear a hat if you've got
the tattoo on your forehead
you got the dui you're going to go
through the classes so you can recover
and get your license back yeah you can
do the best
you're going to do the best you can but
you still got that scarlet letter
yeah i got this girl second a dish don't
let it happen to you
don't let it happen to you all right we
got leadership strategy of tactics we
got the code the
the evaluation the protocol this one is
freedom field manual
brand new versions been out for a little
bit now way the warrior kid one two
three
and four mikey and the dragons often
called the best children's book
ever written sure so a lot of people
call it yeah
i dig it at least quite a few of them i
agree
uh about face by hackworth and then the
og
extreme ownership in the dichotomy
leadership we got echelon front which is
a my leadership consulting company
we solve problems through leadership go
to echelonfront.com
we have ef online dot com
on there we have courses on there we
have leadership courses on there we're
doing live q a
all the time if you want to improve look
leadership is not an inoculation you
don't get a shout out you don't read
extreme ownership one time be like oh
cool i'm good to go doesn't happen it
doesn't happen to anybody
you need to reinforce those learnings
you need to
expand your knowledge how do you do that
efonline.com
go get it muster we just got done with
orlando
freaking awesome we got phoenix august
17th and 18th
las vegas 28th and 29th check
xtremeownership.com
if you want to come to that do it quick
they're selling out ef battlefield we go
walk the battlefields and
go through leadership lessons learned
i'll let you know when the next one of
those is coming up
and if you want to help service members
active and retired their families gold
star families check out
mark lee's mom mama lee she has a
charity organization
she does all kinds of things to help
veterans one of the major things that
she does
is she gets them medical treatments that
might not be covered
by the va or by the military medical
system one of the big ones is hyper
hyperbaric chamber sending guys out for
30 days to get multiple iterations of
that type of treatment and it's
extremely helpful for people a bunch of
my friends have gotten it's been awesome
if you want to help you want to donate
or you want to get involved go to
america's mightywarriors.org
and if you want more of my nagging
narratives
or you need more of echo's vexing vocals
you can find us on the interwebs on
twitter
on the gram and on the facebook
echo is that echo charles i am at
jacqueline and thanks once again
to bill posey what
what an awesome opportunity to sit down
thank you for everything you did for
america and everything you did for the
teams
hooyah warren officer posey and to the
rest of our uniform personnel out there
thank you for what you do to keep us
free
and to our veterans thank you for your
service and sacrifice and also to our
police and law enforcement
our firefighters paramedics emts
dispatchers correctional officers
border patrol secret service and all the
first responders
you all work hard every day every single
day to keep us safe
thank you for what you do day in and day
out
for us and everyone else out there
remember what bill posey had to say
remember he said if you can think if you
can think you're dangerous
if you can think you're dangerous stay
dangerous
stay dangerous age apparently
age is a number and you can go hard and
you can keep going
and we all have more to give so i say
we step up and give it
and until next time this is echo and
jocko
out